Hey fuckers were back crazy,
isn't it?
I'll answer my own question.
Yes, Joe. It is. It's crazy.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience is brought to you by, Oh,
you going with nature box? I was
going to say tank. Naturebox is fine.
Let's start with them.
It's fantastic and inevit.
Naturebox is a, an option that you
can get delivered to your home,
to your office snacks that
are far healthier than
anything you're ever going to
find in a vending machine and you can get
them adjusted to whatever your dietary
requirements are. Like me,
I'm essentially gluten free.
Occasionally I've fuck off and eat
a hot dog or something like that,
but for the most part,
I don't fuck around with bread,
so I get gluten free options. They
send me things like blueberry Ahmond's,
which are great. These big island, a
Hawaiian pineapples are also fantastic.
You can get things that
are very low in sugar.
They have no artificial flavorings,
no hydrogenated,
nasty fucking weird oils and shit.
Your body doesn't like to
digest like Zero Trans Fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup,
nothing artificial, free shipping.
Also anywhere in the u s naturebox is
a great option to avoiding the nonsense
that you get inside vending machines.
If you're hungry and you're at work,
healthy snacks, barbecue,
kettle kernels, um,
everything bagel sticks,
south Pacific plantain chips and
other one of my personal favorites.
I get them delivered every week and they
usually gone within a day or two cause
I'm kind of a fucking pig. Uh, these,
there's pistachio clusters also these, uh,
cocoa almonds. Ah, they got
a lot of good options. Um,
and if you're into very specific
dietary requirements, like low sugar,
they can accommodate all that kind of
stuff. There's a lot of different options.
And A, I'm a big fan. It's
all very delicious too and
a lot of it is, you know,
completely guilt free. Um,
and if you go to naturebox,
go to naturebox.com forward slash,
Rogen,
that's naturebox.com forward slash Rogen.
You can get 50% off of your first box.
And I guarantee you, once you do it,
you're going to love it and you're
going to want to do it all the time.
It's a a way better alternative than most
of the stuff that you're going to get.
If you go searching for snacks.
Even at a grocery story you mean you're
going to have to really pick and choose
to find healthy snacks that have no
artificial flavors, no artificial colors,
no nuns,
and it's like trans fats and
high fructose corn syrup.
That shit is really bad for you.
If you want to find out how bad,
go watch a documentary called king corn.
Find out how it all
happened and find out what,
what that stuff actually
does to your body. Uh,
naturebox is a way to move around
all that shit and snack guilt free.
You need calories, you
need food, you need snacks.
Go to naturebox.com forward slash
Rogen again and get 50% off.
Your first box of Yummy naturebox
foods were also brought to you by ting.
And what Ting is,
is a no bullshit alternative to the
cell phone coverage that most of us get.
Most of us get cell phone coverage from
the big companies and you got to deal
with a lot of stupid shit like contracts.
Ting provides you with the same service
that you would get if you were on sprint.
They use the sprint backbone and they
rent time on it and then they sell you
that time with the sprint rules.
They sell it to you with
no early termination fees,
no contracts as far as like canceling,
cancel anytime, anytime you want.
And they sell the best
android phones available.
All the coolest groovy android phones,
like the HTC one or the Samsung Galaxy.
Now it's s five,
the new ones pretty fucking slick and
the new and actually has a, um, it's,
it's got a fingerprint sensor,
a heart rate monitor and it's waterproof.
Good googly Mowgli. Where does it end? Um,
the waterproof is sweet though.
I'd love that option.
I have the galaxy note
three and I fucking love it.
It's giant and it's really cool
if you want to go online with it.
When I used to go in line with my
iPhone, um, it was kind of like just,
it was okay to do better than not being
able to go check out something online.
But I oftentimes when I'm on the road,
I don't even use my laptop.
I'll just use my galaxy
note three the entire time.
These a android phones have not just
caught up to iPhones in my opinion,
they've passed them and a lot
of ways features, options,
just not just the big screen but the note
three, the one that I use has a stylus.
You can write notes on it and then those
notes I use Evernote and it actually
sends those notes to my home computer
so I can look at my notes on my laptop.
It's pretty fucking slick.
Um,
Ting also has it set up so that you don't
pay for a specific amount of minutes
every month.
You just pay for what you use.
And I think that's the model that all
cell phone companies are going to use
eventually because a lot of times you're,
you're only using a certain
amount of cell phone minutes,
but you get in fucking robbed
because you're paying for much more.
And if you get over that minutes
or go over those minutes,
then you get hit up with a big fee.
You get hit up with extra charges
because you use too much service.
It's fucking stupid.
With Ting,
you use what you pay for and I personally
believe that that is going to be the
model that they all use in the future.
I think when companies
like ting come along,
ethical companies that do things
correctly and they're cool about it,
they do cool shit.
Like on their two year anniversary,
they slashed all their prices.
Um,
and especially helpful for
people who are heavy users.
People are heavy users
and heavy internet users.
They made a big impact on people's bills.
In fact,
98% of people would save money with Ting.
It's because they do mobile differently.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save 25
bucks off of your first device.
That's rogan.ting.com we're also brought
to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t,
a optimization website and it on it.
We Sell Shit that makes your body and
your brain and your mind work better.
We sell things like strength
and conditioning equipment
like steel clubs and
maces and ab wheels.
We have fitness DVDs like the extreme
kettlebell cardio workout DVDs by Keith
Weber,
which are just excellent workout DVDs.
You want a DVD that just kicks your
Dick Right into the dirt with a 35 pound
kettle bell. I know that sounds
crazy. Like Joe, you don't
know me. I'm a manly man.
Trust me, bitch. 35 pound
kettle bell will fuck you up.
If you do the right
exercises for 40 minutes,
it will get you to the point where
you're gonna have a goddamn heart attack.
We also have a really cool kettle bells,
the primal bells and the Zombie bells
kettle bells that were designed by an
artist to, uh, not just be
functional but also look bad ass.
The primal bells are the
great apes series. We have
gorillas, orangutans, chimps,
and howler monkeys that range from 18
pounds all the way up to 72 pounds.
Um, uh, if you're gunna
start any of these, uh,
an exercise program with any of these,
whether it's the Zombie kettle bells or
just regular kettlebells are the gorilla
ones. Pualie's start slowly,
learn technique first,
learn the correct movements
for whatever they are,
whatever exercises you want to do,
start slowly and build a base.
Don't you start with heavyweight and
try to be a fucking meathead and hurt
yourself. Learn if you can from someone
who actually knows how to do it. Um,
if you have someone around
you that can teach you,
whether it's a trainer or what have you,
go to them and get the form down
and then build from there. Uh,
if you don't have anywhere in anyone,
anywhere near you,
you can learn from a lot of online DVDs
or online videos on youtube or what have
you. We have a bunch of different
ones also available on on it.
So ones that we recently made
that show, uh, some of 'em my,
and Aubrey's a favorite exercises.
We also sell all sorts
of supplements and foods,
whether it's the warrior protein bars
that are made out of buffalo and cranberry
with no preservatives,
14 grams of protein per serving,
and only 140 calories with only two grams
of fat as well. Super healthy for you.
Really a a guilt free healthy protein
snack protein bars like the hemp force
protein bar and a hemp
force protein power powder,
stuff that's made with the finest hemp
protein, which is very easily digestible,
super good for your body, very
healthy stuff, and very low sugar.
One gram of naturally
occurring sugar per serving.
It's sweetened with Stevia,
which is a,
a a natural plant extract that is a
very good for your body and doesn't fuck
with your blood sugar levels.
Super good for you.
Go to [inaudible] dot com it's Oh and,
and it check it out.
You could spend hours there just checking
out all the different information,
articles, videos, and see the,
the finest of supplements.
We literally only carry the best
shit that we can find, um, because we
are not available in retail
stores because we don't have, um,
outlets that we have to,
uh,
take care of and hire employees and pay
for rent and places we can afford to
sell things that are a much higher
quality at a very, very reasonable price.
So go to [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t used the Codeword Rogan.
And save 10% off any and all supplements.
All Right, ladies and gentlemen,
we're about to go live
with a freaky podcast.
It's going to get down to some very,
very interesting subjects. Young Jamie,
cue the music,
the Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Todd, uh, Dylan and Liam Reznikov.
Am I saying it correctly?
Liam is a guy from the underground,
from mixed martial arts.com. We've been,
uh, online friends. That's how
you say it. Online correspondence.
Carswell yeah. Well there's
a brotherhood, uh, on the,
the underground that's,
uh,
it's one of the most interesting mixed
martial arts websites in the world.
I think it's the best one as far
as access to information. And, um,
you think I put up the, the Helio
Gracie chronicles two, right?
I can't comment on that because at the
time I was a Btt guy and now I'm a Hoya
Gracie guys, we're going to have
to move these things. The, um, how,
how are you going to set these
up so they could see, uh,
we could see your faces better. Oh
yeah. Scoot over a little bit that way,
that way, that way it's not
a hope in Leeann's face. Um,
and um, so Liam, uh, put the,
well, you get in trouble for that.
Did you get in trouble for that?
There was a guy with a similar name to me.
He put them up, I think. Oh, okay.
Okay, cool. Whatever, whatever.
It totally wasn't you. Oh yeah.
Right. Absolutely. Anyway, um,
recently, uh, you put up, uh,
uh, an attention Joe Rogan
thread, which will they,
those things go up every now and
then on the underground. Yeah.
It's usually like you suck your
mother's a whore or something like that.
I didn't want to enable anybody by doing
that. You know, he bought a thought,
you know, we're coming through America
and you know, we're coming to la,
so he's got to talk right into this.
Sorry, just bring it around to you.
I didn't want to enable anybody,
so you know,
they're going to come out of
the woodworks, the Weirdos now,
but they'll come out anywhere.
There's no way you could stop them as
sitting at the table with you now. Yeah.
It's the Internet. So, um,
you, you contacted me and uh,
I'd seen you online, I know that you
a, you run a gym in Sydney. Yes. Yes.
What's the name of your gym?
[inaudible] Academy in Sydney and
VT one is a MMA teach more there.
You guys have pretty much
all mixed martial arts.
It's sort of like a white color
academy with some UFC fighters,
that sort of thing. So it's a good
place for regular folks to train. Yeah.
Oh we starting to scout
whole and we've kind of,
it just keeps moving forward and we've
ended up with a big academy by mistake.
Yeah,
well that's the best way to do everything.
But just follow what you love and it
all happens absolutely by mistake.
And so you put this thread up about
you and your brother Dylan being
in town, your brother Dylan, being a,
a former championship kickboxer
former professional motorcycle racer.
And just the beginning of the,
the thread was so crazy because you were
a motorcycle racer who stopped doing
motorcycle racing because
he had too many concussions.
So what are you going to you
in a fucking Thai boxing? What?
What is and then he became a
champion. That's right. Yeah.
Sound like a lady boy today.
It what's going on or your voice.
It's a great way to reach you in the UFC.
Oh,
we had one of the last day this
last week and came back and he,
we always lose off.
That's why he's lost his voice now.
So he sounds like one of your
students was fighting in the UFC.
How did he do? Oh, he
won. He was saying, Oh,
Z to win in the prelim thing of it
was, what's his name? Richard Walsh.
Filthy rich. Okay, cool. Cool. Yeah,
he was one of your students. Awesome.
He was on the flight paths and a
lot of people saw it, but he's,
I think he's going to be a straight
the face. Well, I was going to say,
should look up,
there's an article about him online.
If you type in the face of
MMA in Australia, cal Noke,
right. He's the big guy,
right. It's the most famous and Hector
Lombard, a lot of folks don't know,
trained in Australia
when he got out of Cuba,
a lot of his fighting initially in
Australia before he fought for Bell Atar.
And then for the UFC, he's not
really Australian as such. But yeah,
you're looking at these amazing fighter.
I have to loves Australia.
He's an amazing fighter of course. But,
uh, I don't think we told them about, uh,
when we were in Canada and like how MMA
has gone down in Australia and it's shot
up in Canada. It's going down
now. So it's, it's, it's been, um,
tell lot of troubles since the first UFC
show. I don't know if it's, um, I dunno,
it's like my theory on it was basically
that we just kind of need someone coming
up that makes it, you know,
like, um, a lot of the guys
were fighting now like, uh,
Jamie and, um, to Hoonah and Anthony
portion them, they're, they're, um,
they're already quite established
before they hit, um, the UFC.
So I think on a, we need kind of like
a GSP sort of character, you know,
and every man sort of guy.
Yeah, I see what you're saying.
Well you need someone who is like a
championship level fighter will look at in
Jamie is amazing. I, it's not that,
it's just that like, you know,
Dylan sing over here weighs about a
63 killers he did for now Isabella am.
But um, you know, there's no one for
him to really look up and go, man,
I can be that guy because a lot of the
guys are um, heavyweights in Australia.
You know, there's no real
light guys. Right, right.
I kind of think that's affecting the
scene a little bit. Maybe it's a,
it's a theory.
It's an interesting theory.
I think if you had a champion that
would immediately get everybody excited
behind it, JB to Hoonah as
possibly a, I mean a potential.
He's amazing. Yeah. Yeah.
Two is tough guy. Um, there's a,
there's a few Kyle know cause also
tough guy and um, you know, there's,
who else is fighting Australia, you know,
he got a hunt who's out in New Zealand.
Yeah. But it's, it's hard for like,
it's hard for kind of like a middle class
Australian kid too, or a rugby player,
which are often private school boys to
kind of look at some like Marchand
who's just amazing fighter.
Don't get me wrong. But
yeah, it's, it's not a, Oh,
that guy's led the way in
the way I'm going to do it.
No disrespect is an amazing fighter. You
know what I mean? I think, yeah, I think,
you know what I'm saying.
So you need someone who's like a wholesome
Australia and regular guy who the
folks can relate to.
Like go on a fucking great guy.
He's a great guy.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. No, I totally do.
I didn't know that a Australian MMA has
started to decline though. I didn't,
I wasn't aware of that. There's not a lot
of opportunity out there at the moment,
unfortunately. You know, like I'm, one
of our girls is fighting in the house.
I'm the one coming up and I'm in,
she was on hold for a year at a time
because there's just nothing going on.
You know, there's just a couple of
local promotions. But how, I mean,
most of the guys move over.
Steve's overstays.
I was thinking of something I was
playing overseas like Carl and, and um,
stay there, you know,
because they have to,
Brian Ebersol went to Australia as well,
didn't they?
It for a while over there for quite
a long time. Right. He's doing now.
He's in Thailand now living into,
yeah, he's having a bunch of issues,
like a physical issues. I didn't know
they had a tough guys had it. Yeah.
Very tough guy.
Very smart guy too.
Very crafty fighter inside a bunch of
back things is a few things going wrong.
Kept him out of action for
a while. Um, so anyway,
so how the fuck does a guy who is
having problems with concussions,
what, what was your rationalization
to not just go into Moy Tai,
but to become a more Thai world champion?
That's fucking bananas.
That seems like worse path you could
take if you've added head problems.
Yeah, I meant like, um, look,
we grew up to much, lots of
both Liam and I, you know,
dad would had karate
schools in South Africa.
We were born and I can be quite at schools
in Australia, so it was in our blood,
like we already were doing martial
arts, uncles boxes, et cetera. Um,
but my dad also racing motorbikes to
barefoot water skiing and look all the
barefoot water skiing.
So that was my first proper
sport with my dad and my uncle.
How the fuck are you barefoot water ski?
Do you want to tell them what they used to
do? Me, I mean, actually funny. No, it's,
if you look at his nose,
he tells everyone a broken kickboxing.
It was barefoot skiing.
They used to the Monkees to chuck
us a on the back of the boat, um,
in Sydney to set a small lake called
Brooklyn and used to be like, no,
you'll be fine. Just chuck us
on a surfboard, crank it up,
put their hand up, you know, you stick
your feet in. And I was like eight.
And then they will just drag
you behind his motorboat.
You gotta understand like South Africans
Sell Africans are what we call like a
white belt and nothing,
they've never walk barefooted before,
but they've got an idea of how to do
it. We saw a few videos, a few videos,
youtube. So this wasn't something
that they were like adept in.
They just give it a shot.
They did it behind a smaller boat when
her South Africa look where we used to
ski and they didn't know anything about
slumming. So they'd get 'em snow skis.
You'd,
you go on both
and then kick one off then
you'd have to go fetch it. Yeah.
Normally the one ski kick it off for that.
She hit you.
There's no lunch kicking off. What
do you mean? So, so basically, um,
like when you slalom slate Lumpski slaloms
sorry,
both a bit sick at the moment you
come up out of the water out of it.
But I dad and uncle and
didn't know how to do that.
So they just put you on two skis and
you'd kick one off and then go find it
later.
It's just,
that's every Saturday we have a bit
of a reputation of being a little bit
different. What it South Africa's a
kind of a crazy place, huh? To madness.
Absolute madness from Cape Cape Town's
not that mad. This is more Johannesburg,
Johannesburg. Cape Town is not that crazy.
Will you just went, it's not too bad.
I met Johannesburg and then you know like
we were driving back from a night out
and we had to cook our response to come
actually follow us back to our house
because we thought someone was
following me. The whole response,
that's the police ex Congo fighters
that like I'm hanging around the
neighborhood, which private security
guards with massive guns and cars.
So you just call them up, look and
walking home. Someone's looking at me,
you call the number and the car comes
and follows you home. You really,
I mean we're not from Janet.
I was in Johannesburg and I was staying
at a place called box book and I told my
other friends,
they want a nicer place in Johannesburg.
I was there for a wedding
and I was thinking pocketbook
book and my friends were
like, are you out of your mind? You know,
we had guides at the front with guns,
like securing the complex and everyone's
got dogs and I was on the phone to my
friend and across the road
there was a shootout. It's,
it's basically like a saint judge Dredd,
the the new one that's film
that's film, that thing. It's mad.
It's mad that you don't stop at Red
Lights. You don't stop at Red Lights,
but if you look at Shirley's, they're
on. They've got beautiful girls there,
so that makes up for it in a
way really so hard to shake up.
Cape Town's different than from, it's a
bit more like it's beautiful in the year,
so keep down safe fairly well.
I had a guy try get into my car when I
was there and I just drove another side
of the road and just disappeared.
They were,
one of the dangers is still and
came home and he's saying, you know,
kicked down safe. And I thought,
man, you know, it's not, it's safer,
but I wouldn't be relaxing. Like it's,
you know, Sydney, Sydney is very safe,
you know.
Yeah.
They did this thing on some television
show when they were talking about South
Africa and all the car jackings.
And so they had all these different
cards that they had wired up to prevent
carjackings mad that they have these
bars on the side of the car that blow
flames on anyone standing next to the car.
That's fucking crazy thing goes ready.
And my dad says, you know, if
we go to South Africa, he's
driving because you know,
you will, we don't, if people are lined up
across the road, I mean, Dylan, no Dylan,
I will stop. He says, and they just keep,
you can't into different to Cape Town,
but he's like, you know, they'll
stop you and then contact you.
The day I arrived there, I remember
seeing on, um, youtube was,
it was only a couple,
it was in November last year.
And I remember seeing a car pull up,
just put guns straight at that window
and they dragged like it was all over the
all over TV dragged, you know, like
four or five kids out of the car,
just throw him to the curb and just
drove off. They haven't got really, uh,
they're really care too much for life. You
understand? It's like, it's like Brazil.
People go,
why would you live there that you've got
a lot of potential to make money there,
you know, and you've got a
comfortable lifestyle. And
again, we're not from there,
but that's our friends who
are from Johannesburg. We say,
why or why the hell would you stay there?
Or they've been there for generations.
You can't bring the money out to,
can't bring the money out.
It's $1 Australian to 11 round. So when
I go there, I shut everyone burgers.
It's cheap for us. What does that even
mean? Will shout everyone. Burgers. Oh,
shots like shout as in like
pay for everyone forever.
It's funny when I'm sitting here,
I'm noticing he's talking
about South Africa and he,
his accent's becoming sell African. Is
it as we're talking about it, I'm a,
how old were you guys when you
left South Africa? One years old.
Well that's ridiculous.
How the fuck can you keep us out?
The African area went to city
even talk you were a baby. It's,
we're from actually funny enough farm
and we're talking about accents. Nobody,
this whole trip has recognized that
accents as Australia because Australians
sound like kind of wait, Canadians crossed
with New Zealanders, you know, like,
cause we watched TV and we
listened to podcasts and stuff.
So you know what you have on your show.
I'm Jim Jeffries.
I mean when you listened to him you
think he's like Paul Hogan son, you know,
because when you come here to be
recognized, he does his farm. So knives,
which is where we're from. Yeah,
I've talked to him off podcast.
Not Quite as Australian where we're
from the same suburb. But look,
he's very funny. Hilarious, very far. Um,
is he most famous comic out of Australia?
I don't think he's,
I mean within the people that we know,
he's not that well known,
but I mean his every now and again
someone to come up and say, hey,
check this clip out. You know? And
he's brilliant obviously. Yeah,
he was telling me that a long time ago.
I want to know if that had changed,
that he was having a hard time in
Australia, that he was famous in America.
It was doing well in America but not so
well in Australia. Australians are weird.
Like if you're an American,
you come to Australia,
your accent will make you
funny or instantly, you know,
like think about our accent.
Like if I say ass say,
I mean in America it's not
tough. It's not funny. It's not,
well there's certain Comedians,
I don't want to name the names,
but there are certain comedians that
get a little bit of extra credit because
they have an English accent.
Like we'll,
we'll accept someone from another country
and we'll pretend that they're way
better than they really are.
And then you watch their comedy like,
like American College, like
the kind of dog shit. Like,
what's the fuck is going on Jackson?
No Irish is that adds charm
points instantly. A little bit.
He's got a Scottish accent as well. Um,
yeah, we, we, we like other accents.
I don't know what the fuck that's
about. Girls love it too, man.
Give me the girls love Australian
accents, right? Don't guys, can we pull it
off? You know, he says
get a, and every time we,
we have never said get that in Australia.
Nobody in Australia says good day,
but you meet a girl over here.
You throw it around like let her know.
We always say
that's the first question we get every
time from an American crews and Kangaroo
Kangaroos,
the furthest you can get on a plane.
What's the furthest flight you can make
in one shot? Is it Australia? La. Wow.
Yeah. It's pretty fun. No,
England's only 10 hours from here.
I was still at the Sydney is 16 long gas.
We haven't slept more than about four
hours for the last three weeks. Probably.
Like we're just not adjusting well.
Yeah,
I've done it twice and it's
a fucking brutal flight.
It's an awesome place though.
I've only been to Sydney.
That's the only place I've been in
Australia. I fucking love it, man.
If I was going to live outside
of America is on the shortlist.
It's the place where we are now.
I mean, not saying where it is,
but where we are now is very
similar to suburban Sydney.
We were driving around and we're
like, oh, this looks like ride,
but you're on the wrong side of the road.
We're on the wrong side of the escalator,
the wrong side of the road.
They don't start everything.
You know that awkward moment when you're
just like walking out of one of those
doors,
you know in Vegas,
who in Vegas yesterday and you walk into
someone and you normally shift to the
left or right. We got left because we
drive on the left. They shift. Right.
So we're both going the
same way. I'm like, buddy,
move without the way you move. Yeah.
He keeps saying, look at that car.
No one's driving it like we're
driving and I'm looking at that time.
There's no one in the front seat
because it's the wrong side.
Just sitting a kid
that baby's driving.
It's pretty scary,
man.
Our Lando and our driver was telling us
that oftentimes people come from Europe
or from England or where have
you and they in their countries,
they drive on the other side of the road.
So they'd come to Disneyworld,
get drunk and get on the wrong side of the
highway. Well, he doesn't let me drive.
He doesn't trust me.
He is the mechanical guy.
I'm the directions and she got a
Mustang. So pretty happy about it. Oh,
you're very excited. Did you guys know
why the left side and the right side,
do you know what the origin of that shit
is? I heard an explanation, but I don't,
I'll tell you what it is the left side,
the reason why they did
it in England and uh,
a lot of those countries is because it
was from way back in the day when people
would ride horses because you wanted to
have your sword arm on the right hand
side. If someone was coming the other
way so you could fucking hack at them.
So we did American go wrong
where they decided no more war.
Fuck it. Maybe. Yeah, maybe it was.
Maybe Henry Ford was a fucking lefty.
I don't know. I don't know what
started it off. Well, it's fun. I mean,
our whole trip, we basically spend
the whole time, Josh, I mean you guys,
you guys in America looking around and
your drive and your board and this an
interstate, this and that. For us it's
like watching movies through our eyes.
You know, like we just drove past Sherman
oaks and I was watching no retreat,
no surrender last week. And we were
just like, that's fucking Sherman oaks.
I took photos, no surrender, no retreat,
no surrender. You never saw that sort of,
that's a karate movie or something. But
back home in the day, the guy's name,
it was van dam's firsts. Oh, okay.
We're going to take photos.
That's [inaudible] areas and silly suburb.
I think we got stopped by there.
It is render.
We watched it last week.
It's the greatest.
Have you ever seen there's John
Claude van Damme reality show. Oh,
where he does a lot of coke
and then whatever these lawyer,
Mike will be happy about that. But
yeah, whenever he does a lot of coke,
it's still like go fuck himself.
I liked the guy too,
but his reality show is God
damn brilliant. He's such a,
he's so crazy. Oh, he's
so off the fucking chain.
Crazy that you watch his reality show
and you just like, he kept, kept talking,
keep talking about this fight that
he's going to have with the tie.
That's like 90 years old.
Well,
it doesn't matter that he's not having
a fight and he's just, you know it.
I know it. He knows it. Everyone
knows that that's filming it.
It's like this weird charade that
he puts on where he pretends cries,
where he starts talking about the fight.
I'm going to have to fight to show the
children I'm going to knock him out.
But it's like the way he talks, it's
like a character in a such a romantic,
like fake romantic, romantic,
like a romantic in a bad movie.
It's like he's become a guy who
speaks in bad dialogue. He's like,
become that guy. Well, I mean, I went
to ask you about that. Um, you know,
he still speaks to that accident,
had been living here forever.
So zone of Schwartzenegger right.
Does he live here? Oh, I mean,
I'm just saying I don't show,
it looks like he's in another country.
It's hard to tell. I, and one of them I
remember he's, he gets, has a spine match.
Just some random sheikh dude and
psychics India. Did you say? No,
I didn't see that
episode. He's um, but um,
they'll saying when we were up in Canada
or someone was saying to know GSP for
example,
has kept his accent and a certain level
because it's so recognizable and no,
I think that was true.
Somebody was saying that George lives
in Montreal and George George speaks
perfect French. I mean,
it's not his accent. I,
when I talked to George outside of the
octagon, he speaks exactly like that.
He does what he does. Yeah. He's
just, he's very authentic. We just,
the reason I bring it,
I was just wondering if like van dam's
handlers or George's handlers haven't
kept him.
You know what I mean?
Like then if he started
talking like it's like this,
George doesn't have those
kinds of handlers. George
has trainers and you know,
Jujitsu coaches and mixed
martial arts training.
He doesn't have those kind of
handlers, but maybe, maybe, but van,
I mean George was just in
that Captain America movie,
but he really didn't talk all that much.
It was mostly him just kicking ass.
You know, it's fun movie.
Did you see Captain America?
Fucking, we watched three.
There's a problem with the movie and
obvious problem was that Captain America
knows the Hawk and he
doesn't call them right.
What isn't fucking world's about to end
and he knows this invincible green dude.
Why wouldn't you just go, hey
look, there's some shit going down.
I'm trying to get my ass kicked. I'll
be right back. I want to make a call.
The hall comes flying in it.
I'm just fucking smashes everything.
The movie's over in 10 minutes.
You know that all those dudes,
like if captain America's Duking it out
with those dudes and they're going blow
for blow, the hug finishes everything in
five seconds to fucking movie is over.
No, no plot to take over the world.
It's over. It's over. Everybody rest,
rest assured that sleep tight
that the Ed Norton went on TV.
The other Vegas Hixon yeah,
with Hickson and the first 45 minutes
of the movie or a him avoiding wrecking
stuff. You know, like he doesn't even do
anything. Just 45. The mark was his name.
Mark Ruffalo. Is that his name?
Fall. Yeah, that guy. He's awesome.
He's the best banner ever. Here's
another piece of American Trivia. Uh,
the, in the comic books,
his name is Bruce Banner,
but when they made the television show,
they changed it to David Banner
because they think Bruce is a gay name.
That's how silly we are.
We're fucking so we love
America are a silly shit man.
So back to you man. How the fuck did the
route get right back to that question.
How the fuck do you go from having too
many concussions in motorcycle racing?
How many concussions did
you have by the way? Um,
have blocks at about four big accidents
on the track. So four out cold.
Kod flatlined probably that three.
If it has three hospitalizations
from head injuries,
um Oh, that was just
from the motorbikes. Um,
well you didn't wreck your body. No, it's
actually all right. That's all right.
So let's just head injuries. Um,
yeah, a couple of, to be honest,
we that she had no major injuries
from barefoot water skiing,
fighting racy blacks.
That's incredible.
It's not the pool riding recently that
didn't got to, it was the worst thing.
You shut the fuck up. You
started go riding. Yeah.
So you're the manliest man alive.
You only do sandwich shit.
That's the funny thing I
loved pool riders could find,
only started getting into it.
Like you love bull riding.
Well I put my shoulder landed upside down.
You kind of stopped doing this time.
We had a guy on fear factor that had
been a professional bull rider and he had
just had scars all over his shoulder.
Hip.
We constructed like eight times and
he said that anything goes wrong,
plop, it just pops out on his
shoulders. Just loose as fuck.
Well the thing is the hospital called
me and my friends call me. Oh yeah,
Dylan's dislocated his shoulder.
I'm like, all right, here we go. Um,
I'm in the hospital,
my dad full 12 times a year.
Just always little things to storage,
stupid things, you know, but,
but they call me and I was just like,
tell them till doing, I'm fucking happy.
He just got his shoulder.
Could it be got to talk?
That's a big difference in the volume.
It's a bit intimidating looking at it.
I always think of it used to it.
It can't be when you say it that that's
a black Dick joke for those at home that
are listening, not watching,
but he'd just called out to me.
So the first thing I did was I was like,
fuck your brother.
I was like basically just like fuck you.
This is because we are in the academy
together as fuck you.
You brought you descheduled shoulder.
You're lucky it wasn't your neck hung
up the phone and I'm not even going to
deal with it because I'm just like,
why are you glad you're writing? Look,
I retired from fighting about a year ago,
year and a half ago.
It'd be living in Thailand
on and off for a long time.
And it's a very hard thing for people
that are like, you know, eight, nine,
10 years in. They create, I
mean look at John Wayne pose.
Actually a good friend of mine.
Yeah, I love that 10 great guy.
And you couldn't say one bad thing
about dark grape grape. Great fighter.
Great Guy. Really good guy.
You got to get him on the show.
I love it.
So funny.
I met him for the first time about
a year ago when he came to the UFC.
I got him tickets for the
fights. Well that guy, big fan.
I went to ask you a question about that
being a celebrity of sorts. I mean,
you are a celebrity I
guess. Um, absolutely. Um,
I was just don't like to kind of like
recognize celebrity to some degree.
Like they feel embarrassed,
you know.
But one thing I was going to
say is looking on the Internet,
I want to know how you deal with this
and I'm taking it off topic again. Sorry.
But um, you know, like some guy comes up
to me the other day and he's like, ah,
Wayne par. Yeah. Here is all fake.
He's a dick and this and that. No,
he's absolutely not fake. Absolutely. Like
he'd got up at 9:00 AM hangover to do,
to treat one of our students to pads. Like
he's the genuine, nicest dude. I agree.
But it just seems like you can't be a
celebrity without some Dick just just
shut, right? Yeah. Making
shit up about, well,
eventually you realize that the only
type of people that would do that,
they would attack you
for no reason or idiots.
So if you're going to live your life
worrying about idiots or worrying about
bitter negative people,
some people are actually smart.
Some people will attack you and they're
smart and they write these scathing
negative things about you that are
not true, not based on reality.
They make these judgements of you.
They decide who,
how you think and they flavor you
and their, their, their posts there,
whether it's a message
board post or a blog post,
but they're just negative people.
And then there's a real problem with
being able to post on the internet,
whether it's posting on a message
forum or whether it's making a blog.
And that problem is, it's not
a, you're not interacting,
you're just putting out a thing, which
is fine. You know, there's, there's,
there's good to that because you know,
you could read things that people write,
whether it's a blog post or a message
board forum posts like on the underground
that could be very informative
and fascinating, but also
you can decide to fly,
you know,
Liam is obsessed with himself.
His ideas are bullshit,
his ideas are,
and you can just go on and on
and on with all of this, uh,
add homonyms and all these fallacies
about a person and the person's not there
to respond. And so if that person reads
it like, no, I'm not what the fuck ass,
but this is not a conversation.
And those kind of interactions
would never take place.
If someone was in front of you, if they
were in front of John Wayne, Paul, John,
where he pours food, he's
bullshit and John, wait, probably
wait, Tom, about my, yeah,
well they wouldn't say to them and
that they did that. He'd be like, okay,
well how am I faking? Explain how
I'm fake. And you be like, well,
I've never done that. Like what is
this guide book would just be like, oh,
that's your problem. It just wouldn't
even react. And he's a self actualize,
you know, he's got personal sovereignty.
He doesn't need a fucking idiots.
He's their opinion of him to,
to define him.
But people will try to define you and
they'll try to define you and a bunch of
ways.
But most of the time,
the reason why they tried to
define you is cause their failures.
Whether they're personal failures,
whether they're professional failures,
their failures, their life
in some way, shape or form.
If they don't have a real interaction,
like you didn't steal from them,
you didn't do anything to them personally.
If they don't have a real beef with you,
they just decide to
start attacking you all.
Most always it's because they're losers.
Yeah.
So you're dealing with a pool of
people that are almost all failures.
What they see in you,
if they,
whether it's John Wayne part like John
Wayne part is a multiple time world
champion.
I mean he's a bona fide bad motherfucker.
I mean he's a guy that look at him.
There he is right there.
And George St Pierre brought him
in to help him with his kickboxing.
I mean he's just, he's,
he's his legitimate, again,
when we're going to
fucking stack of belts.
Well a guy who sees a guy
like that and you, you know,
men measure themselves against other men,
they don't like it.
Imagine is Ebay store. I have had fucking
conversation with someone like a, Hey,
what's up? Hey, how are you doing?
And then fucking that one person will
tell someone else some 20 minutes story
about what a Douche I was. Cause I
didn't say, Hey, what's up the right way.
You know,
people just decide that they're going
to define you because defining you in a
negative way somehow or another makes
them feel less bad about how they compare
themselves to you. When they compare
themselves to guy like John Wayne par,
they come up short. I mean, he's a
fucking savage. He's a rare human being.
So you compare yourself to them. You don't
like it, hey, that guy's a fucking fake.
He to this. He said that people
love to just chop people down.
It's that crabs in a bucket mentality.
You know,
a crabs in a bucket is put a
bunch of crabs in a bucket.
They can never get out of that bucket
because as they're trying to get out of
the bucket, the other crabs
pull on them and drag them
down. Well, Hey, he actually,
I mean, you can talk about it
instead of me, Austin you, but um,
I mean for a fighter it must be terrible
because you can get knocked out and you
look silly when you're knocked out.
I mean, not silly, but I mean it's,
it's not a nice moment,
right?
This is a video of a guy coming up to
Rashad Evans with a photograph of when Leo
Machida knocked him out.
You know that famous photo cause he
got really knocked out and he was
unconscious. The Guy was asking Rashad
to sign it with a big smile on his face.
Well you stopped going dead after a logon.
Yeah, I had him just riding for me, man.
I was his publicist.
Yeah.
Basically I'll just take off the
internet and that there's other,
the other problem is this anon anonymity,
the ability to post something as you
know [inaudible] 69 you need to make some
fake name up and you could just say the
meanest shit about somebody you know,
instead of like a photo of you.
And here's my background
is where I went to school.
This is what I've accomplished in my life
and this is what I think about Dylan.
You know, instead of saying that, you
know, you just post some nonsense,
some fake account or fake name rather
anonymity with sensitive information and
insults, it just doesn't
work that way. When you,
the thing about insulting someone,
if you define someone in salt,
someone most of the time there's like
an evaluation process during that
insulting,
like the guy,
like if someone's a fucking 300 pound
guy just shit his pants and he's calling
you a loser, it's really difficult to
take them seriously. It's like, oh,
I'm a loser. But you know, if
someone's an anonymous poster online,
all that evaluation kind of goes away.
It's like,
do you take that person's
opinion seriously? Yeah,
it is. Look at the underground. How many
fucking pros posting the underground,
where's the last time you saw John Jones
posting on the underground was the last
time. A lot of them work. They
go in to creep around, they look,
but when they post just
so many fucking assholes.
I mean Tito Ortiz is probably like one
of the last guys that stopped posting,
but even he gave up after a while. How
many times can you hear people anonymous,
14 year olds to shit all over you.
You know?
But I treat it like snake venom and I
feel like you get bit by a snake and you
could really get fucked up,
but if you get bit by a little
bit of snake venom every day,
you get immune to it.
That's how I look at it personally,
but it's an,
it's just a side effect of this stage
of interaction because there's not going
to be Indiana anonymity
and you know what I mean?
It's not going to be an anonymity
within the next decade or two decades or
whatever.
It's going to be.
Enjoy your privacy and your freedom now
because it's not going to exist 20 years,
30 years from now. It's just not in a way.
I mean for a guy like me,
it's normal because I'm already not
anonymous so I'm already out there,
but I think everyone's going
to be out there like that.
People are going to pretty much know as
much about you as as humanly possible.
Yeah. Well that's coming
on the show. It's funny,
we talked a lot about this and I'm,
one of the projects we're doing is
with that I'm with the growing down.
What is with a psychologist and he,
we were talking about it and being
on the show and stuff and you know,
we've got a business that we teach
kids, you know, we teach adults and um,
we teach a lot of sensitive people
and like a white collar area. Right.
And the psychologist friend of mine,
Jonathan back, he's a, he's on the,
on the other showed he um,
he took him a while to open up a little
bit because he was worried, you know,
people get a lot of information about
you on these things, you know, and um,
they can judge you, they can use it
against you, this and that. Like,
especially if you're somebody
who likes to talk like we do oil,
I suppose you do as well. And just give
opinions and think and shout things out.
It seems like it might be a little
bit dangerous. What did you write?
It looks like a Dick. What'd you
write? What? Just worn it? What?
Worrying about the effect of what
you say can have it a public scene.
Whereas if you're a buyer, you can say
whatever you want, you know? Right. Well,
yeah,
there's definitely gonna be a lot of
people that judge your thoughts and your
opinions and how you express yourself.
But at the end of the day,
it forces you to evaluate your thoughts
and your opinions and how you express
yourself and you, you know, you have to,
you have to own your words and you have
to mean what you say and say what you
mean. And once you do that, you're
like, I'm comfortable with it.
There's not a single thing I've ever said
on this podcast that I feel like, man,
that really are really
fucked up when I said that,
because now people have a
different opinion of me. My,
my opinions that I say on the
podcast are well thought out.
And I'm lucky that I started
it, you know, later in my life,
I didn't do a podcast when I was 20
when I was a fucking idiot. You know,
I think back on that like, God dammit,
if there's podcasts from when I was 20,
oh my God, he could hold it against me
to the end of time because we all learn.
We have to be, if you're going to be
out there and you gotta to take chances,
you're going to fuck up. You know,
and you're going to fuck up socially,
intellectually, uh, along the ways.
The only way a person learns is by
trial and error, trial and error,
and absorbing information
from other sources.
Those are the way you learn on your
own by your own failures and your,
your attempts at,
you know,
accomplishing things that you're
not really qualified to do.
And then you learn from other people's
information and from other people's
failures. But that's just what we do.
But when you fail online, man, you know,
I mean, how many fucking knock out
animated gifs? If you seen, I mean,
for the longest time, remember that
Guy Fred Adish? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Poor fucking guy was torch a Fred adish,
she's a guy who fought in UFC one and
he fought Johnny roads and Johnny roads
beat him down. And, uh,
there was a guy who started a website
called the Fred editor are rife for it,
fetal fighting style.
Like,
cause he curled up in a fetal position
what Johnny Rhodes has beaten them down.
So they were torturing this puff
fucking guy and he's, he's quite,
he's fought against since then. He had one
fight MMA. Well, you learn Jujitsu, Lee,
you know, it became a real MMA fighter and
yeah, I think he fought more than once,
but you know,
he's a legitimate martial artists.
He just like a lot of us back then,
before the UFC came along,
he didn't understand what
real fighting was about.
He thought that his karate was enough. I,
you know, when I was doing taekwondo, if,
uh, if the UFC had been around
when I had only done taekwondo,
I probably would've thought that taekwondo
is enough and somebody would have
taken me down and strangled me. Um,
when I first went into kickboxing,
it was a huge realization to me that I,
I thought that taekwondo was enough and
that I was getting my face punched in.
I was like, oh my God, like there's
so many holes in this style.
And then I started more time and I'm like,
Oh God dammit kicking the legs.
And then it was Jujitsu. It was
like, oh well fucking Christ,
I've spent all this time doing this one
style that I thought was sufficient.
But that's what the UFC was all about.
It was exposing the world to the
effectiveness of real martial arts.
I'm laughing because I ended up doing
Jiu Jitsu extensively and he did white.
So I,
but he ended up doing Jujitsu because
every time we get into an argument over
Mirc Jujitsu would wick,
oh yeah,
I'd take them down strangle.
Well,
most people have no idea how help us.
They are in the ground until it happens.
You have all these and you
know, Dana White and I had
this conversation in a day.
He used to joke around about it,
but he was still always think
if a guy tries to take me down,
I'm fucking hit him with an upper
cut and do this and do that.
Diana says in the old days,
I used to, not now, no.
He's like, I really thought that
before we went, we, you know,
we own the UFC before I started learning
about mixed martial arts. He's, it's,
it's like we laugh about it
because everyone has these
preconceived notions and
you don't realize how helpless you
are until you actually do it. Well,
he's got to bounce it to hit
you now, so I'm going to, well,
nobody's hitting anyway. He's a
sweetheart days. One of the nicest guys.
The point is that most people
have no idea how help us.
They really are until they
actually roll. Yeah. Hey, hey.
He proceeded to Jitsu quite
seriously for a while. As a result.
How frustrating is like, leave,
get the hell off the computer.
It's too easy. Right?
It's fucking frustrating.
He kind of just like near your brother
in the face. It's not, you know, you try,
try, try it. Well, I've
tried once the credit,
well at least you're a martial
artists though. They're,
the really crazy thing is when you
get someone who has no martial arts
experience whatsoever and
you know, he'd go, okay, um,
lie on top of me and try to keep me
from strangling you. Ready, set, go.
And they'll try to like hold you in
place and then the next thing you know,
breath isn't fucking 10 seconds. They're
essentially a dead man. Yeah. You know,
it's,
that's the beautiful thing about Jujitsu
and that's what you Jitsu showed the
world. But these poor guys like Fred
Edis and these poor guys that had to,
they had to be the reason why we learned,
we had to see these guys learn.
We had a c,
you know,
these guys get taken down art Jimmerson
with his boxing and one glove on.
You know,
we had to see these guys getting taken
down and our Jimmerson wants a rematch
with Royce Gracie and she's,
I can talk to him recently about it.
He's a bit cut a little bit,
taking a few of those.
But in Thailand, it's funny. Um,
it's getting a bit better now,
but every time we'd go,
there were a couple of places like super
that had a cage and the tires would be
like, yeah, I'm going to fight him. Amaze
soon. I've got a big heart, you know,
I can and clinch there
clinches ridiculous.
But when you hit the ground that
don't have the ability to relax,
they just don't, they
don't really get it. Yeah.
It's a shame but it's a very
different thing, you know,
especially a more or any,
any kind of striking going
from striking the grappling.
Like I've seen friends that are good
boxers and they got very good endurance
like hitting the pads. They can hit the
bag for, you know, five, six rounds,
no problem there role for a minute.
And they were exhausted.
We just don't understand this.
A totally different style of moving,
conserving your energy is just
a, but you know those guys, man,
we owe such a huge debt of gratitude to
the original UFC fighters because they
showed us with their own humiliation
in their losses. You know,
and even guys who are like
bad ass is like Orlando Veit.
You remember that guy that Moitai
is going to be out of animal man,
the commentaries, oh, he'll
be out of this shortly.
Lucky is rem co Pardue
elbowed him into another universe.
That was a horrific knock out too because
he was trapped on it as giant judo guy
who just smashing him with elbows and
his head, his head is stuck there.
He's just Bong, bong. It's huge judo
guy just crushing him, you know?
And then he gets crushed by
Marco who os and the hoists,
Gracie and all these other people. We
learned, you know, we really learned what,
what real fighting is.
So many of us had all these like
crazy ideas of what fighting was.
I think I was like 12 and
I was in England. Oh, in
England. I went to England,
do some holiday family and they've said,
listen man did it.
You got to get me this. Um, this crazy
cage fighting. It's illegal in Australia.
Like you couldn't add black in Australia.
What knows? You see one of those three?
Those three? Definitely two was the
first one that came out on video.
What year was this?
We watched it in about 25 I think.
But it was definitely three because voice,
I was expecting us to smash
everybody and then he pulled out.
So first we have watched because in
Australia we just didn't have access.
It was just, we used to trade
VHS tapes overseas, you know,
that was the only way we could do it.
Right.
Was that one of your businesses for yeah.
Well in high school I
couldn't get ahold of her.
So I had this UFC three tape and then I,
I legally sent it overseas
to trade it with somebody.
So I had to tapes and then we had three
tapes and then I'd trade three and I'd
have three tapes,
six tapes,
etc. But I remember we watched it and
we wait until everybody went downstairs
cause we thought someone was going to die.
So we were huddled around the thing.
We pushed play and of course nobody
died because nothing back. Well,
they could have though, man, because the
medical tests they did on those guys,
fucking nothing, man. You know,
there was nothing going on.
There's three people in there and
hope they survived. And Joseph,
it looks like he probably has been messing
around on a corner a little bit. Well,
you know, Joe signs in jail
now murdered someone now. No.
Well he murdered someone in jail,
but he went to jail because he was a
part of a gang rape. Yeah, they did a,
I don't know what happened.
You got arrested for something
else and they, uh, they,
they matched his DNA sample
with an unsolved gang rape.
I'm laughing at the giant cross. Anytime
you see someone that extreme, you know,
they're going the other way.
Short Joseline used to hang around the
comedy store and before he ever got
arrested, and he was so weird,
man. He called everybody sir,
call you sir and mister and he
would hug everybody. He was really,
really weird man. It was a really
weird, cause he was like five foot,
two inches jacked just in the, and he was
hanging around and everybody was like,
this guy's fucking crazy.
It was like a weird dog that he was like,
you were hoping that didn't bite you. And
everybody's like, yeah, nice dog or cat,
you know in Australia,
you know like when we have weird dudes,
you don't generally worry about um,
getting stabbed or shot in America.
It's a real concern with drugs and
stuff, but we just don't have, um,
you've done have that imminent
sense of danger that you guys,
obviously this is a safe,
the safe areas,
but you just don't hear about
it in Australia as much.
There's more fist fights.
Is that what it is? Fist foot bottlings
as well. Bottlings are chosen.
That's fucking scary
shit. Coward, punching,
punching, sucker, punch,
hit. If you hit someone,
why you're intoxicated or even,
I don't know what the exact goal,
it just got passed. It's
massive. Chelsea killed,
got hit and died by this big juice head
who said he was an MMA fighter and that
was bad. So he got sucker punched
and he got, well they were,
they were two or three kids arguing with
him. Uh, they will kind of like, you know,
well dressed sort of kids and the guy
hit one of them and then he fell and hit
his head. He hit his head and died. And
um, they want to change it to say, um,
it's not called a sucker punch or
king had, it's called a coward punch.
It's Australia kind of rallies
behind these odd things like that.
And now they've also made
it that you can't go out,
you can't come into a bar after a certain
time. I got locked down after this.
Doesn't mean we ain't got much,
but three o'clock, you can't,
whatever club you're in,
you've got to stay there. Like
you can't come and go, Huh?
What is that?
It they've got no common sense.
It's just a keep the decay down the
street. So when you go out with your wife,
they're waiting on the corner,
rejected from a club. So
it's worse. Well, you know,
I man,
the idea of having these places where
people consume the worst drug ever for
social behavior and
it's all over the world.
Alcohol is the worst drug ever for
social behavior. Lowers inhibitions,
makes you feel like a bad motherfucker
when you're not, gives you terrible,
shitty judgment.
I mean,
it's like the worst drug as far as
like getting involved in fights.
If we had pot clubs, if we had places
where all you could do with smoke pot,
you go to a place and just
eat brownies and smoke pot,
there would be no fucking fights. Nobody
wants to fight on pot. They just don't,
even if you're thinking about fighting,
like I gotta go, I gotta get Outta here.
That's all. Canadians
are so nice, like crazy.
That is nice period because they're
not trying to take over the world.
Big fucking problems with, uh, America
is an, America has got this long,
deep history of trying to take over the
world or defend against other people
trying to take over the world.
So it's just fucking group of
psychopaths live in writer. Neat.
These nice folks to the
north. Yeah. Well, no,
he just went to Quebec and Montreal
was beautiful. Zack, he's wicked fun.
Fantastic. Oh, the Canadians are
the nicest people in the world.
That's the other short list place
that I would move to Vancouver.
You ever been to Vancouver? We went
there for one another. God Damn.
That place is awesome. Amazing. So, uh,
another city that I really thought about
moving there in 2004 after a Bush won a
reelection,
I really thought about moving.
I was cause like everybody's so
fucking crazy. He wanted again,
like how could he win and
how the fuck did that guy,
when after all this nonsense
that everybody knows about him,
it's crazy fake war that
they drag this into.
It's not a real war under fake pretenses,
but I was like,
this country is going to turn into some
banana fucking republic police state.
Like we gotta get Outta here for us
living in Australia. I mean it's,
it's a very much a candidate.
It's very relaxed and um,
it's almost a little bit too fortunate.
And I had a friend move here because he,
um, he just said it's really easy
in Australia to be middle class,
but it's very difficult to make a lot
of money and be upper class and there's,
there's just, America
just has that kind of, um,
the ability to [inaudible] move
up as a bit of romance. Right.
Maybe you don't see it as for us.
We see it. I can imagine. Yeah.
I could see that they did the caste
system and the class system that exists in
England and exists in a lot of
other places in the world. Yeah.
I think it was a really bad,
isn't heavy. Some of the,
we went to Manchester and it was a
bunch of rough kids walking around with
babies because they give them, um, they
give them a house if you have a kid.
So there's 16 year old girls
everywhere with baby baby.
I'm pushing the pram,
socialize,
socialization. It was pretty funny to
watch this young chicks everywhere.
Kids and red hair. That's weird.
I didn't know that. It's a,
that was like our families there as
well. Socialist ideas. I mean there's,
there's, there's good things
to it. Like healthcare.
I really think that's one of the big
problems that we have in America.
And they try this good, like the
way they're fixing that in America.
It's like fucking up even more.
Obamacare and the affordable care act,
it's got so much,
so many people are angry about it.
But,
but I think that the principle behind
public health care should be that.
That's like one of the first things that
a government takes care of first things
that a society or civilization takes care
of me. What should everybody have? Well,
everybody should have
access to healthcare.
I mean she'd be like
one of the first things.
It shouldn't be that everyone has to go
by it though the day of they force you
to go buy it. I mean it's
this weird sort of, you know,
we have the money to,
to start wars and finance
these overseas campaigns,
but we don't have enough money to take
care of the health of the citizens based
on the tax revenue that we generate. And
I think that's just crazy. Well, you guys,
you guys have to keep crap job's just
to keep your health set care right.
Sometimes many people,
too many people take and keep jobs
just specifically for their health.
Takes advantage of the health care
system in Australia. That's for sure.
Back to the whole of Australia have gone
up because it'd be fucking bull riding.
So back to the thing.
So you,
you have all these fucking cush
concussions for three big ones,
three,
three out cold from motorcycle riding
and you decided to go into Moitai um,
tell them what you want it to do in
between then and why you got into Moitai.
So basically I decided
to join Israeli hobby.
We've got family over there as well.
And this school I went to,
some of them decided to go over there.
I was dating Israeli girl as well.
I thought I'd go to the
Israeli army and I was 18.
I thought a good joint would be a
good experience cause my dad was the
paratrooper dog unit in South
Africa. So I was like, hell yeah,
this is, this is the brains of, yeah.
This is the sort of, the thing is,
is this girl's moment convincing him to
go to the Israeli army romance decent.
Israel is very romantic
and meanwhile she's moved to Australia,
so her daughter doesn't have to
go to the fucking off the charts,
get a baby for sure. If I go down,
it's like, so that's why you,
so how do you join the Israeli army when
you're living in Australia and you're
Australian citizen? Born in South
Africa. It's voluntary. It's voluntary.
So they'll take anybody from
a Jewish background. Um,
it's voluntary.
You could join the Israeli army.
So you're from a Jewish background,
that's all you need is correct.
It's all your name. That's all you
needed. Wow. Really? Diversity. Oh really?
It's up to three years
of pretty active duty.
So you go over there,
you're 18 you join the Israeli army.
I didn't quite make it there,
so I told my parents and my dad was,
tell your parents.
That's the whole point of the story.
I told them that three days before
it's going. Why did you tell them?
I'm terrified of my dad.
He's like the nicest guy ever to just
went out of the, I said that. Um, yeah.
And they're like an eight.
I'll go ahead and get the big guilt trip.
I cancelled it. I had a plane ticket.
I'm like, screw this labor ready.
I mean he's a couple years older than me,
so like screw this,
I'm going to go to the toilet. They
want the same ticket. My parents like,
you're going to Thailand,
we're paying for him to go with you.
I went as a chaperone,
all expenses paid first night we
arrive there when straight to seven 11.
Got a massive bottle of Samsung.
It's a tie whiskey and just got like
absolutely drunk off my head on um,
coach San Road Bangkok,
which is like a bad area,
but it's not a bad trash. It's, it's a,
it's like the Vegas trip friendlier.
You know,
it's a bunch of cuts friendlier than the
Vegas trip. Well not if, well look, it's,
it's basically backpackers central.
Um,
everybody's very friendly cause they
usually straight out of school and they're
free and the way they're fisherman pants
and drinking and smoking cigarettes
going there just for vacations.
Gross. Oh city. Okay.
So lovely. So, but you're not alone.
There's probably a bunch of other people
drunk like that too. They got him drunk.
Yeah, I got, I got the,
the the ironic thing that got drunk or
the corner with the homeless Israeli guy.
Yeah. It was the funniest part of
all of them in a lot of Israelis.
That's hilarious. So then ever since
then I was like, man, I love this,
this fighting business.
Like I was ready boxing's does
young liberals do Jiu Jitsu?
Obviously I looked up to him or I was
doing Moitai and thought I was good at it
and then he got 10 times better than me.
I was like screw this man,
I'm just going to live here.
And just kind of kept going back and
loved living there. And what will,
what was it that like forced you to like
make that decision? Like, what, what,
what triggered in your mind to like, Yo,
okay now one more tie fighter. Yeah. Look,
I've been at school wash. Dot. You
know, I did so much struggle at school,
but you know,
I have add share on 80 days.
It's even remotely interesting.
Yeah, it is struggling. I thought,
you know,
like all the be something good and boy
wasn't established in Australia yet.
Like there was no wind power was still
very good.
But it's something that you sell in
Wales is a video on the thread on the
underground. Um, I mean on a
message board of him fighting,
pull it up so we could put it on
while we're talking. Yeah. Yeah.
It was a video of you
finding out my message.
It is a world championship title fight.
That's the one he got no to ask him about
that actually that was the second time
and his whole career he got knocked out.
Like to actually watch yourself.
And I've watched this a few times
when we find in there. Yeah,
that's Sunny d from New Zealand. A really
good fighter. Um, this was actually,
I was still getting told to this day
some of the people's favorite fights
because we kept dropping each other
in it. And, um, this is quite an,
that's my coach Nick Stone. Um,
yeah, I just didn't have a good eye,
good training camp for it. I
just, you know, it was kind of a,
I wouldn't go that look, it's, I was
getting, I had too many coaches, whereas,
you know, I should have had one
that we've looked everything.
And you're getting contradictory
information. Is that what it is?
We didn't really like the prom was with
moisture in Australia and he's got to
coach Nick Stone who is a brilliant
coach, but it's, um, you know,
we had a bit of boxing, a little bit
nutrition, a bit of this, a bit of that.
And it's,
it wasn't how we coach our students.
It was just basically do
a little bit of boxing,
a little bit of running wish for the best.
Like it wasn't,
you weren't totally organized
that were saying, yeah. You know,
I can always go back and forth between
Thailand's he know the tires like no, no,
no, you kicked like this. And he'd come
back to Australia and off. Fuck this guy.
What was the difference between the
way the ties told you to kick and the
Australians told you to kick? The tires
are more dominant in clinch elbows,
knees and kicks,
especially clutches.
What I love the most about
Whitesides is my favorite thing. Um,
whereas Australia and you
generally find like Sun even out,
I'm just watching the video now
is very well known for his hands.
So the whole career only took about 12
to 13 hits to my head in all my flights.
Real was wasn't someone, if you watch and
again 12 to 13 hits ever to your head,
how's that possible? Many you have? Oh,
34 34 fights in only 12
to 13 hits to the head.
I like to stand when you say that.
Right. But um, it's gets really
excited. Get around my tie.
Fighters take much less
damage than boxers. Um,
it depends.
Um,
you know like I really a lot of the
articles in the MMA forums and stuff and
these guys coming out saying the
damage is getting done in the training.
It's not getting done in the cage.
Right. For me, my trading Thailand,
we don't even really spa.
We do a lot of clinch,
a bit of play spidery lot of pad work,
a lot of groundwork.
Well they have a down more, you know
in my opinion is about MMA sparring.
The real problem is that MMA in
America and MMA as a sport in general,
it's still very young.
It's a very young sports and there is
a lot of people that got into MMA that
really did not know how to
properly train for striking.
Absolutely properly trained as far as
like what kind of damage you do long term.
If you spar really fucking hard all the
time and it looks as always have had a
history of, you know Jim was and much.
Yeah. See the thing is like when,
when Americans went to Thailand,
they saw the ties training and
they copied it and brought it back.
And this has happened in Australia a lot.
Um,
it's one of those flat to constant watch
you when you stop, that's what happened.
Yeah. Sounds sick. But um, the problem
is that they watched the ties to it.
And this is like anything, when
you go overseas, you do yoga,
you do [inaudible] whatever art you're
doing, cooking, whatever it is, right.
And then watching the Thais do
it and the ties go pads, bag,
work clinch and that's it.
So the Americans had come back in a
strength come back and copy of that,
but they forget the ties don't spar for
one reason. They fight every weekend,
you know, so from a young kid so they
don't spoil. Why would they spar?
That's right. So right. So
I mean, I think like, um,
that was lacking and clinch is really
lacking in western countries. But um,
ties don't, if you watch him fight,
have you been to Thailand? Jury? No.
You going to watch them fly around
the fourth round? If one guy has one,
they stopped fighting in the fifth
round so that they can fight next week.
They know who's one already,
you know the first round that I go hard.
They don't dry elbows for the first round.
Normally there's a lot of
that sort of stuff in India.
They go slow in the first round. Is that
because they also want to place bets?
There's big part of the
adrenaline adrenaline. Well,
because the adrenaline will take
a bit to kick in like two. Um, I,
it's like the plum harm down
and find your rhythm. Look,
the problem with Thai boxing
is like he's been, how long?
How many times have you been 26.
26 times. I've been about seven.
16,
17.
It was on about our 10th trip that a
tie actually explained the rules to us.
Saxon. Yes. Sex Saxon. Right. And it's
like [inaudible] no, I wish, but no,
that's that. He's an, he's an American and
Axon is a, the name of the gym sessions.
A guy he beat, um, you
know, some core, some cores,
like the best kicker in Thailand.
He was just, hey look, a,
you become the best kicker at Tyler.
Oh some cores whose country
is known for a while.
But this guy explained the rules to
us and we're thinking Jesus like Ooh,
beautiful. Knocked down. By the way,
that was not illegal for people that
actually lived in Thailand and kept saying
it was illegal.
Why was it illegal as long as long as
you throw the cake before they're down,
you can kick.
Sometimes they land on the ropes,
he can still hit them as long as they
didn't hit like the floor. Oh I saw that.
Its critics out there. But what was the
point of this? To me down, we're tight.
Thai, Thai boxing. One of the
misunderstandings, people don't,
they don't understand
like you know the ties,
they won't fight in the fifth
round. They won't use, you know,
elbows usually in the first couple
of silicon cottage and then the,
and that was illegal right here.
Bridge from this fight.
Really one shot to the back
of the head while you're down.
Um, yeah you were down. Totally mucked
style. It's in how got a little bit dirty.
It happens again. Wow. Side
of Brady. Everybody try it.
I remember going to the hospital for
awhile and this was the fight that
convinced you to stop fighting.
I had a one or two flights health
to this and yeah, no big deal.
Just a brain hemorrhage. Yeah.
Wanted to fund. They have
to drain your brain. No, no.
It was only a small blade,
but it was enough to, yeah,
you look like you're certainly a
wobbly here. Oh, I keep going. Damn.
The thing about about it, this fellow that
is, man, it didn't have to be this way,
like if you didn't get hit on the
back of the head and then again being
dangerous. You know what I
mean? Right. I like it. It's,
I hate to say like when people hear
us say that it's the sport and Moitai.
Is Jen really quiet,
pretty safe compared to boxing or rugby?
Rugby's a horrible smell.
Love sport by them.
And how is it safe when you're dealing
with head kicks and Shins and knees?
I mean, how many head shots
have you seen this? Oh,
he dropped him with a head kick.
This is a crazy fight, man,
that could fuck holy shit to get dropped
like that and get punched in the head
while you're down.
Then get punched in the head again and
dropped and then dropped him with a head
kick. And then I think he wasn't
cheap back of the head again.
But it was only when I kind of went down.
Oh.
So I think this flight
had changed to South Pole.
That's coming of at one of my lady flights
were changed to South Pole. It's wild.
Um,
so the difference in the way the ties
fight being that they fight like almost
every weekend and then they train.
But even their sparring,
they don't go at it full blast.
Like the Dutch who don't
fight as much as the ties,
they throw hard kicks to
the legs into the bodies,
but they throw light or
punches to the head. He says,
we were in Holland about a year
ago training at MIT at all.
I wouldn't say which
Jim, but um, men that's,
there's a punching each other's
heads through the wall. Oh Man.
Especially when the jet, um, I
was maturer ratios. Jim's crazy.
That's a great gym by the way. If you have
it, go there. Have you been there? No.
Well there's the used to be a Magiro
gym in Encino as a Guy Shuki from Magiro
gym and uh, Holland came to
America. He was here for a while.
He's an Israeli as well. Uh, he went
back to Israel though. Well, anyway,
go to the locker room and just be prepared
to keep your eyes facing straight.
Yes.
There's group showers and everybody's
naked guys and girls talking and chatting
after training. We weren't ready for
that. Yeah, wouldn't you be ready for that
next to none of the guys would
go shower together as great.
Beautiful. Back to the garden of Eden.
What? We weren't ready for it. Wow.
That's cool. So she's a kill
each other and trying to know.
So how did you decide though,
like that you were okay doing this?
That was a beautiful head kicked man.
How did you decide that you were okay
doing this after like retiring from
motorcycle racing because of concussions?
I mean,
you weren't worried about
these concussions like this.
That's some bullshit right there.
Like I hit you aren't,
that should have been the end of
the fight. Yeah, I kept going.
There's another one
coming up. Um, but look,
I can't take it away from this
sky to get off topic cause he,
Sonny is a top flight. Oh,
he definitely is. But he's
also, if he's a dirty
bitch, I not going to lie.
Doing actually has a
lot of respect for him.
I woke up for about three months after
this fight dreaming about strangling. Oh,
that was the first fight.
He's a lovely guy.
Everyone tells me I get up every morning.
I woke up dreaming. I was just like,
squeeze it. You hit him when
he was down to payback bitch.
Crazy fight, man. That's a crazy fight.
This is the first time you really got
hurt and your whole career down in Jamaica
on a big show, but not so
dehydrated. We were like, oh yeah,
my coaches are going to be one 35
pounds. I'm like, Oh yeah, 62 kilograms.
I get there. And Stevie Kennedy's,
uh, one of my coaches as well.
He's a heavyweight. Um, I'm
thinking, you know, one 35 pounds,
it's probably around 61 62 didn't
think about it and get there. I'm like,
shit man, I got a cut. Like I
swear to you, end up 58 killers.
It was like 58.7 or something
and had to get done.
I don't even know what the weight was. I
was like, 64 kilograms is Jamaica. Wow.
Pounds. How many kilos it
was, you're talking about
you're talking to eight kilos,
eight kilos off. How's about
five or six? Six, seven, six.
Let's say six. So six is, is 2.2 pounds.
Jesus Christ. And back then
we didn't like, you know,
we didn't know many of the cutting
methods to sit at the site for five hours
saying about sang about this.
You know what?
I'm sure it's the same for you with
everything you do. Like we didn't, we now,
the way we coach, how we didn't know back
then or how we want it to be coached.
So we just didn't know, you know, so
he'd just go jump in a sauna suit.
And so what we did. You just did it. Yeah.
There was a lot of really bad weight
cutting it in the UFC back in the day.
I used to cut weight to fight in
taekwondo tournaments. I cut the day off.
I would get down to 140 pounds the day
of the fight and he's going off my hair.
1617 yeah. It was terrible for
a very dangerous they will.
That was the thing about boxing while
they changed it to a Wayans the day before
the fight because they give the
fighter a chance to rehydrate.
The big issue was brain injuries too.
Dehydrated fighter or more substantial.
Of course I found out that almost all
the deaths and boxing came and outside of
the heavyweight division in
the heavyweight division,
there was no deaths. Yeah.
That's one of the things he attributed to.
This is not cool to watch.
It's one of those flights will be the
greatest fight ever if you weren't the
guys probably I made the best highlight
of this. It was just me hitting him.
If we don't have to watch it again.
It's cool.
It's cool cause you can keep going cause
I want to ask good questions but um,
yeah,
there's a theory now they're saying that.
And I was saying to one of my guys,
because we just went to the UFC and he
cut about five pounds and everyone keeps
saying you need to drop down a weight
division. Right? Yeah. This is not cool.
That's it then that was not cool.
There's the end of the fight.
That was the back of the head shot again.
How's it going? We can kill off Jim.
What's your view on that? Sorry. Um,
so that you fired two times
more after that. How many,
how many MMA fights or excuse me,
I'm more Thai. Did you have total
I had a couple of like,
um,
you know we kept my record down cause
I was fighting to Thailand a lot.
So if those guys,
I've never been passed around to hit
Thailand in 1617 flights everywhere.
So all up we, we found a lot of
tapes and probably about 30, 34.
Yeah, there's a lot of fun.
Dodgy towards the end. Yeah.
I started finding bigger ties
and just like, there's some,
there's some good ones on youtube
of I'll be fighting is twice a year.
I dropped him like 15 times
the Calbert get tropic.
Those guys just keep getting back
up. So I don't know. I didn't really,
it didn't bother me fighting tonight.
You've got little kids,
eight year olds that are fighting
and it makes you feel, you know,
in Australia when it fought, it's like
you go backstage, got to rev yourself up.
You've got all your friends. There you go.
You know, it's the crowded, it's music.
Thailand, there's like eight nine, 10 15
year olds all sit in the back with him.
Mommy's taping the hands. You watch
them fight for, I taped their own hands.
That's right. Yeah, yeah. You
know, they, they fight for
like 15 minutes. You're like,
oh, this isn't so bad. You know? So it
was pretty more relaxed environment,
easier going into the fight.
Absolutely. Playing as well.
And I was normally in the main event
being like the Westerner and I started
finding some really good tires to subcu.
Really started towards the end.
Getting a little bit dodgy like cause
ties are very proud people and other very
similar Japanese like that.
And they started kind of slipping in
the bigger dude's and snapping in the,
there was one fight actually showed
me where he was actually winning.
And you throw me just to get his shoulder,
but it was a bit scary until then.
Kicked me in the head is a big boy.
So when you say bigger dudes,
you mean like the wrong way class
outside of your weight class?
Like ringer's ringer's after a while.
Are they bigger than you?
The legs. They're trying to
set you up. They didn't really,
they didn't really weigh you do though.
Now we here anyway. I just, most of them,
most of them were either weight or
heavier earlier on. They used to Ab bits.
Um, yeah, later on they're just
kind of all about my size or bigger,
which I was okay with. It
was still good fun. Wow.
So you far over there for many years
and were you there when the tsunami hit?
Yeah, so excuse me. Um,
basically the story with this,
um,
I don't think I even written
this online, but basically, um,
we wake up and Yanks who actually
the other side of Thailand and um,
my brother and I and Cobain Yang and I
was still staying there for quite a while,
having some fights and my brother's like,
listen man,
I'm going back to Sydney call say cup
or a bit of money on my Kia suede.
Like I had so much in my bank.
I was like 20.
And he went and took it and
he entered the pin card role.
So he entered the pin number wrong when
you put the card in. And I was like,
great, such swallowed my car.
I was like, I'll fucking great.
So I'm stuck here in Copen Yang,
which is like the full moon party,
like crazy party island.
And I had to wait like four days to
get a replacement card. In that time,
my friend had two doctors
that lived in Melbourne,
Glen and Tom and I met them a few
times. One time. I said, listen,
you guys go to PP island,
you go to the other side of Thailand where
we wanted to spend years in Christmas.
And I said to him, well, you guys go
there and I'll meet you over there.
I've got to wait from our placement cuddle
still. Therefore a couple more weeks,
I'm sorry,
a couple more months in Thailand.
So they went over there
and then it's tsunami hit.
So in a way I kind of miss it and army
because of my brother. So I'm like,
okay, well like screw this,
I'm going to go look for them.
And we didn't know what actually happened
because the media is often run by
governments and we didn't
really know what was going on.
So we had ours a bit of a wave and um,
yeah,
basically where there's a bit of a
wave and you know, I thought, oh,
we'll try help out. I'll go look for my
mates. So I could, I got a friend, um,
to write entire saying, I'm head of
the Australian Search and rescue.
So I went over there with a,
another South African friend who I'd met
who is now a very good friend of mine.
And they're like, okay, cool. You
guys are in charge of um, pick up.
The bodies were like, yeah, this
is just fucking great. Yeah.
And we've got more involved and you know,
there was those 1500 bodies when Ppi
island, we, it carry all of them.
There was just a couple of
volunteers and stuff. Wow.
And then after a couple
of weeks we're like, well,
we tried to do a few other things. Um,
you know, we, you know, those things,
they wanted us to start cleaning up
because a lot of disease on the island
because of the buyers,
because of the body.
So then the animal study
eating the bodies as well. Oh.
So bodies would be washing up, you know,
all the time. What kind of animals? Um,
what actually happened during the
tsunami was in Ppi on its flat.
It has got two hills on the other,
on both sides,
and that the animals must have detected.
There's a lot of articles on that,
on the Internet.
I detected that the slammers coming in
and they actually all went into the hills.
So there was like, do you like dogs,
cats, birds, whatever. Um, there's a goat.
We found running around, like loosened
a lot there and I was doing, um,
they started in the bodies and
then they got sick as well. How?
It's only a small island. Um,
and those, you know, I was like,
how big are crosses it he'll walk
from one side, you hover, it's not,
it's not that big. But um, yeah.
So, and then I was like, well shit,
I bet it's keep looking for my friends.
So we went through the bodies with,
through the pictures in the morgue, went
to the morgue. Meanwhile, these two,
two monkeys, they're both
fun. They're both doctors.
And I actually had gone across to PB
on, it's a bit of a trip, you know,
like ferry, bus, ferry, two
monkeys, none. I if I, two,
two friends that are doctors, you don't
really mean really monkeys, monkeys.
We came tongue.
Um,
and basically they met some girls on the
bus across and into, stayed in hotel.
And I don't know what
the hell they were doing.
So I'm looking for them in the tsunami
and I pick up bodies and do all types of
crazy things we probably shouldn't have.
And um,
and they were just on the mainland
hang out with these two girls
so it all where they there to find
them and they'll just chilling out. Um,
but you know, Alisha, I suffered a
lot of, um, not so much, but more so,
uh, post traumatic stress
off doesn't it? 20, 21. Um,
yeah and stuff. A lot of post
traumatic stress and um, you know,
it ate that much and just
from the bodies will PTSD.
He wasn't really like talked about as
much as the stage, you know, like I,
I felt like I was a warrior as I call
it. They're not talking about this. Yeah.
To be fair, my mom was like, don't
even think about going over there.
And I was like, yeah, hell no, you
don't. No mom, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it. Yeah. When
straight straight over there.
And we had some cool experience.
Like every day I could write a book on
the things that we did and what happened.
And that's the idea actually. Yeah.
When you say post traumatic stress,
like specifically, like what, what
was the feeling like what did you,
what was the issue that you had
from seeing all that horrific shit?
Um, look, you know, I mean folks were
actually what happened when I came back,
my prints split the day I
got back from the tsunami,
so they split and my brother and I
would just in the house alone. So, um,
I dunno, like, you know, we'd be what?
She was a bad boys two as your favorite
movie. Yeah. I love that close to there.
He loved that. Wow. You really did get
hit in the head a lot. It's cool man.
Um, yeah, bad boys two and you know, we'll
see the bodies in this way. You're like,
everybody's there much sick. Will Smith
so bad boys two, what would happen those,
that same with the morgues and
stuff like that and bodies and yeah,
like a little bit of a flashback and
yeah, that, it was just kind of hard.
It wasn't something I talked about.
It wasn't something I was proud of.
I was like, Oh man, I put
everyone out. You know,
I probably shouldn't have done that.
And they're a bit of guilt as well where
you only told me some of the stories,
quite recently talked to him about
it. That's one of the reasons I, um,
I put that post up because
we were so busy in Sydney.
Everything's always
moving, moving, moving.
We never actually sat
down and talked about it.
All I know is he had some trouble, you
know, and we see each other every day,
you know, but just, it's never just
come up in conversation, you know.
So today on the way here we were talking
into the plane stuff or toy and I'm
like, I've never heard of these
stories. Has some cool stories. Yeah.
Which is strange. It's
strange I guess. But uh,
that's what it is for a 20 year old.
I think it kind of,
I grew up very quickly and I went
back to Thailand a lot since then. Um,
yeah, those, those cool
experience. I later,
like now I've been
working for the customer,
we rescue team for about three years now,
so I'm the only Westerner that does it.
Only idiot. Yeah. What is the rescue team?
What does this in Koh Samui they've got
private ambulances and then they got
volunteer and there's the rescue teams
of like a boat flips or there's a car
crash or local sick or someone
dies or there's a lot, you know,
there's a lot of black acts and
stuff, you know, we go click,
the bodies are lingered on Westerners.
Yeah,
we go like patch him up and take him
to the hospital and it's a bit of
everything. You know, there's
a fire where they're like,
we kind of Gi Joe kind of rescue me,
but I'm the only Westerner.
So that led to that later on and I've had
some pretty cool experiences for three
years now. Just working a couple of
shifts a week with the Thai team.
And you one shift of
probably the hardest shift I had was
last February when I actually decided I'm
going to retire and the cord limb
of sendlane retire. And I was like,
if I'm gonna retire and
have to try that much.
So I spent a lot of time doing the rescue
team and over the full moon party on
the island up from us in one shift from
11:00 AM until the next day 11:00 AM
those like 30 accidents we
attended. Yeah. So it was pretty,
it was pretty hard to get
published, you know, as well.
We're not really allowed to talk about
all of it, but most of it's, you know,
western is drunk. Westerners just being
stupid. And I meant there's a girl, um,
I think his sister is Nicole
Fitzgerald and her a young sister,
Kate and Nicole.
Um,
it was on the back of a bike and I don't
know if there's a western a and got hit
by a truck and she died and now
I know she promotes safety for,
for riding and transport in the Asian
countries because a lot of like a lot of
Australians are dying folio flag
balconies and p kit and to stupid stuff.
Just being drunk and [inaudible].
Yeah. Thailand's amazing.
Make it sound worse. Like, this is the
worst part of it. It's amazing place.
But people just go there and it's um,
you know, the ties are lovely people,
beautiful people.
Very patriotic.
Like if the king of you don't
talk badly about their king,
if you're going to have a pension,
they king or you've been to the
movies there and what happens?
You have to stand up
and king for the king.
It's like 10 minutes and one
west and I'm an idiot. Um,
refused to stand up and they just, of
course warm happen would happen. Like, um,
don't know what happened. Exactly. I
just know he was taken away. Basically.
They'd beat his ass. Yeah. I mean
they're not, they're kind people.
So I don't know if they'd beat his ass,
but they would have find him or
arrested him. You don't know. Wow.
Just for not standing up at
the movie theater for the king.
I think he got arrested.
So talking back to their country folk,
everybody who goes to,
you know,
like right now you go there and you go
to these places and the key with going
overseas and you've traveled quite a
lot of, of course we travel like a lot.
When you go to someone's country,
you never go to the place where Westerners
hangout. I don't want to see Aussies,
I don't see ties at deal with Ozzie's
cause the ties that deals with deal with
Aussies, they get that red. I'd
look and you know, they get,
it's just a little bit like they're not,
they, they become, I'm jaded. Right.
So it's just like, um, you've got to go
to their country and respect it. You know,
if you go to Thailand, then you
must, it's an amazing place.
Don't go to an area where ties have to
deal with Westerners because then you've
got to deal with the tires that have to
deal with the West. Well that's, I mean,
Hawaii is a part of
America. Um, but that's the,
the argument that you always hear
about Hawaii is how the hate Americans,
but it's just because they're dealing
with Douche bags all the time. I mean,
imagine the fucking idiots that you
have to deal with that are always on
vacation coming from all parts of the
world and they're all drunk and they're
all, uh, you know,
entitled because they're spending so
much money to get over there to act like
you should give a fuck about them.
You know,
I've met people that are Hawaiians in
Hawaii that are some of the nicest,
kindest, coolest, sweetest
people you could ever meet.
But then you'll talk to people,
all wines, hate Americans. Like
maybe some, maybe for a
fucking good reason. You know,
maybe they have to deal with
dickheads, ties, ties, hate Israelis.
Really because,
and Israelis have you been to,
it's a lovely place I've ever been to
Israel imagined Copacabana without crime
really. It's pretty much what it is. Tel
Aviv your full plate. No crime, no crime.
I mean the, the, you go girls, 18 year
old girls with machine guns on their back,
you know, at Mcdonald's off
duty, you know, but wow,
that's an underrated traveling places.
But everyone's so scared of the bones
and all that stuff. Don't worry about it.
The point is they hate Israelis and
Thailand. So we'd go buy a motorbike,
which anyone could have any girl,
Aussie girl who gets off the plane can
hire a motorbike, never driven one before.
And um, we go high. What are they say? Oh
no, sorry, we can't lend you. And we say,
oh no, where Australian. They
go, oh, okay. We thought you
were Israeli. So, so what,
what, what the reason is Israelis
a nice people? It's not that,
it's just that the ones that go to
Thailand, uh, fresh out of the army,
so they're, they're crazy. You know, like
they're just straight out of the army.
They've seen all this bad stuff and they
go to Thailand and they just smoke weed
and just go create that.
Whereas they just go crazy.
Basically mushrooms and everything
disrespectful towards the tires, alcohol,
flights, whatever, you know, loud,
because they feel entitled after the army.
But you know, the ties to like
them go there. They're nice people.
Far off for the moment.
The young traveling Australians,
the Russians aren't doing so good now.
The Russians have like,
there's a lot of Russians in coast movie
and the islands in the past two years
I've noticed, especially working
for the rescue team. I mean,
tell me more and more Russia
and they speak Russian, uh,
mobile, Russian accidents.
And because our last name is Latvian,
Russian really raised a lot of us.
We thought it was Russia until about
a month theory, Pharaoh's Latvian. So
basically a picture of a
cricket. Yeah. But now, you
know, when I went to hotels, um,
and I can speak Thai,
so for me it's like I can get around it.
They see my last name raise look off and
they're like, no, no, no, no, we're full.
I'm like, you gotta you're blind. It's
like 300 rooms. There's rooms open.
I could see them really speak to them
when their call and once they realize
you're Australian. Whoa. Yeah.
But if I spoke Thai, they
kind of really take you in.
Oh, do you speak Thai? Oh,
it's a bit rough. And he's
very, he does, he's bloody shy.
That's every time I said Dylan order for
us to speak to untie it. No, no, no, no.
He speaks. But my team didn't speak
English at all. No one in my rescue team.
So sometimes those
misinterpretations about, you know,
I did interpret things properly when
they speak to me. Tired, they'd be like,
go over there and you know,
like I'd drive to like the other
side of the island if I was,
I was driving the ambulance
and uh, some some, yeah.
Not so funny because the one thing about,
um,
one thing about Thailand people don't
know is that before the tsunami couldn't
buy property, there are businesses,
unless you are under a Thai name,
so you'd marry a Thai woman or a top man,
which is great.
I think that's a good thing. The tile ends
should be owned by tires, you know? Um,
but after the tsunami, they allowed
foreign in this foreign investment.
So if you go to [inaudible],
which is where the beach was film,
that's where he did his rescue stuff.
Um, I just not recognizable anymore,
you know,
so anybody can buy a business and
property there now that wasn't like that
before.
That's changed a lot because of that.
I mean before that you've got people who
have to go round and round in circles
to set up businesses and brothels and
strip bars and stuff like that. You know,
now just give him money. You can do
those Russian strip clubs in the middle.
I'm a mom with Russian strippers in the
middle of like clubbing areas. Yeah.
It's crazy. Yeah. I mean,
look, you've got to go.
It's an amazing place and the people are
amazing. That's small parts you know, of,
of timeout. Like there's still a lot of
untouched areas, especially up north.
There's amazing.
Do you think that it's going to change
irrevocably because of this though,
because of allowing Westerners to buy
businesses there is that kind of fuck
everything out?
Look,
I know a lot of expats that live then
I'm a lot of South African expats as well
as a big ex ex pat community and it's
nice there, but like anywhere, like,
like my brother said, you
know, there's bad areas, um,
like specific bad areas and out of a
whole island it's only a small area.
So now I didn't really
go back to them anymore.
I restating that it's not exactly bad,
it's just this young people getting drunk,
drunk, crazy, like spring
break all the time basically.
When was the last time you went to spring
break? It's been a long time, you know,
really into it. Even when I
was on spring break in college,
I wasn't really into it and my dream,
it seems really great place to
get stabbed isn't too crazy,
isn't worth going well. I think whenever
you give someone the opportunity,
like this is the time, it's
New Year's Eve, let's go crazy.
Like people go crazy on their own.
You don't need a big fucking a
day where they're allowed to go.
Crazy third party in Thailand, the
half Moon Party, the quarter moon pie.
And even more days to go, well, there's
a lot of clubs do New Year's Eve nights.
They do stand up comedy shows.
For the longest time I avoided those
just because I got tired of the drunk and
crowds on new year's or so crazy.
It just wasn't worth doing.
But no telling where we spent
new years top and hunting,
you have to tell you, well,
here's something for you.
Every time we speak to an
American or Canadian, we spoke to,
there were these two
guys that, um, the UFC,
a Antonio Cavalla real nice guy and
his friend monkey, who's a really good,
um,
he doesn't use his real name and they
live up north in Canada and they hunt
fucking bears and wolves.
And with automatic rifles in Australia,
you can only get single shot bolt action.
And they're saying to me,
I'm like,
we're going to come next year and you
guys are going to take us hunting.
That's be fun. And he
says, he said, uh, I said,
why don't you come to Australia and
honey goes out of your fucking mind.
I'm not coming to Australia. What do you
mean? He goes, come to Australia and hunt.
You guys got the most
dangerous animals in the world.
And I'm thinking like you just said,
you hunt wolves and
bears.
We the only thing that Brown
snakes [inaudible] south Wales,
so there's no crocodiles.
Where are the crocodiles there?
Up in the northern is and stuff.
You've got to be careful.
You don't step in a puddle there
hiding underwater,
terrifying scene where we are there.
But the thing is for us,
like the scariest creatures and sees
a is a brown snake, which is deadly,
but they don't want to be there if you're
hunting and bloody Canada that bears
and polar bears, if you
keep going up, you know,
bears and wolves of wall tacos
whenever any that attacks us.
Yeah. Well the, so the crocodiles there
are limited to one part of the island.
But what about the water? The swim.
Yeah, but I mean you're talking about,
we're talking about like Bush
hunting, right? Like, like
in a Bush, right? But, uh,
but swimming up on the
top side of Australia yet,
don't just have to worry about sharks.
You have to worry about crocodiles,
crocodiles, and outreach. And what
part is that? What is the, the
up above Queensland, Queensland
sort of upper along. Yeah,
there's not much up there.
Have you guys seen that guy who's a
claimed to be Jesus in Queensland?
It's become a fairly famous
on the Internet. There was
a internet expo's a about,
um, some, uh, I believe is a British guy.
Went to a Queensland and talk to this guy.
He's got a huge colony of people up there.
That belief he's Jesus.
He's got some woman with him that
he says Mary. So she's a whore.
Well,
you know,
she's a reincarnated horse
or I don't think her herself,
but a, apparently, uh,
this guy's a causing a stir up there
and people are hoping he gets eaten by
crocodiles. He's got a good chance as
long as the puddle around says that bad.
Um, in terms of the policy, I mean,
look the [inaudible] or anything
like that, right? Like a bear,
you could probably run around a
tree, like a black bear. I Dunno.
I've never seen one. We're looking
at doing is actually doing three. No,
I'm saying as in like a blackberry.
You could probably shoot it
or climb or something. Right.
Not at, not a brown bear.
At the smaller ones,
you know?
You know how fast a black blackberry we
want to go next year can literally get
up a tree as fast as they can run.
They go there. Just go up the tree.
You're not going to out climb a
blackberry. Sure. I got a good black belt.
Could strangle it. No, I don't think
so. No, I don't think you could.
You could shoot it.
I mean most of them are scared of people
because we usually have guns and bows
and arrows and stuff. Yeah, but
black bears are tricky, man.
I've never seen one there. We've known
they don't usually attack people.
Black pairs are much more likely to run
away from people then attack people if
people have died because of black bears,
brown bears in their hand or fucking,
yeah, fire. Sorry. Grizzlies are totally
different animals and happy Hopkins.
One there with the bear. That's plenty
chasing him around. I remember that.
I don't remember the name of it.
Terrified.
The polar bears are the most
dangerous. Really? Yeah.
Because there are 100% carnivorous.
The other ones are omnivores pro.
Even grizzly bears are omnivores,
but we'll say that, I'm sorry,
brown bears hunt a lot.
They'll,
they'll kill moose and they chase
moose and chase him down and kill him.
They chase antelope and or um,
uh,
a rather a Caribou and d or the
Fonz, but they a, and they'll,
they definitely kill people. They kill
people every year. They killed people.
Even in America every year.
That's Brown, Brown, Brown,
Brown bears and grizzlies
essentially the same bear.
Black bears are smaller but still
very dangerous. But all those bears,
they eat different things.
They'll eat like roots and berries.
But if a polar bear sees you, they
just go, oh shit, I can eat that.
And then they start coming at you.
They all just want to eat.
Anything that's moving is on the menu.
But what about wolves are, they're scared.
They're scared of the bears will just
scary as fuck. Cause they act together.
If it's scary thing about wolves as
they act together, they haven't been,
there haven't been very many
attacks on human beings,
but it's only because we figured out
how to contain them and killed them.
They used to be a lot of them.
I mean all that big bad wolf,
all those stories that, you know, Little
Red Riding Hood and all that stuff.
That all came about because
at one point in time,
before the wolf populations
were put under control,
especially back before they had really
good weapons. Wolves were a huge problem,
right?
During World War One,
the Russians and the Germans had a
cease fire because the in in the the,
the, the forest, they were killing
so many troops, the wolves,
they ran into a super pac and wolves,
a especially in like the really
cold climates conform superpacs.
There's also a principle of the further
north you go, the larger the mammals are.
That's why polar bears are the biggest
bears and Kodiak bear because you,
the further north you go, the more they
have to maintain their body mass or to a,
in order to keep heat.
So you have enormous wolves and they,
there were so many of them that they
were killing so many Russian and German
troops that they got together and they
made a cease fire. They said, hey look,
we're gonna just kill these walls and
then we'll go back to killing each other.
But she's a famous incident telling
me like, I was like, Whoa, whatever.
Cause we got dingoes and then guys alike
didn't go as a kind of like crack heads.
If they kind of gang up,
I'll kind of follow you.
You're cutting and you know you're in
trouble. Well, but dad was jogging once.
He saw one Diego and he kept jogging and
he still kept joking and then he sold
on Fraser Island is quite a phrase on it.
Nice and straight up and
bring some anti Dingo weapons.
Well he's just done jug on your arm.
Bring red bands big either.
I like dog's 70 pounds, 60 pounds. They
kind of like, do you guys have good,
someone similar in cocktails.
They kill people every now and then.
The woman died a couple of years
ago focusing or up in Canada. Punch.
Coyotes killed her. She was
19 years old. Young Kid.
Apparently a talented singer too,
but the wolves that they're starting to
shoot now in North America are really
fucking big.
Get Jamie,
pull up a picture of a big wolf
that someone's killed. They, they,
they kill these wolves and they
take pictures of him after shooting.
They're like put, putting in a
bear, hug hugs and hold them up.
So you see how big their, you know, there
are 150 200 pounds. They're fucking huge.
I could never shoot a dog.
You say that. But yeah,
when it goes a bloody circle in you all
love humans. But I'd shoot to kill me.
Show you the size of that. That's
one of them. But that's, that's,
that's a perspective shot. The wolves
in front of you. It's, it's to tell,
show a one of the ones where a guys
picking up a wolf because there's,
some of them were guys are holding
up these wolves and you're like,
that is fucking insane. It's bigger
than a person. Oh my God. Yeah.
Look at the size of that fucking thing.
And they have a lot of them now in
places like Idaho and Montana. They're,
they're starting to, uh,
to shoot them and uh,
put hunting seasons on him
and Ma put larger, um, uh,
tag limits on him as well because they
want more people to kill wolves. A lion,
they're big. See, here's another
one. The of that Australia,
we've got the smallest,
we get the bloody little spider that
kills you and a snake. Well, the,
a lot of these are reintroduced in
North America and the thing is they were
almost decimated in North America.
So they brought in the Canadian
wolves to repopulate. And then again,
here's the issue. The further north
you go, the colder the weather is,
the larger the animals and so that you
get in these larger wolves. I mean,
they're the same species technically,
but it's just like,
like white tailed deer.
Whitetail deer in Mexico tend to only
be here like around a hundred pounds.
But when you get up to Alberta,
whitetail deer get to like two 50,
300 pounds sometimes because it's much
colder and they need to have more body
mass to keep their body heat
up. It's pretty, pretty amazing.
Australia pretty awake, like
crooked. I was probably the worst.
The funniest thing was Vegas yesterday.
I was,
I met up with a friend of a friend
and shit. I was like, you know, you,
your boyfriend got to come to Sydney
some time like Sydney because then every
like, you know, if I go there, it's
just everybody wants to kill me.
I've heard that way. Everything is
trying to kill you. That spiders,
Americans has been there. That's
how, you know what, here's the thing.
And she's like, Oh man, I heard about
those drop bears. And I was like, Yay.
Shear is, don't give that away. You
don't know about drop bears there.
What's the drop bear drop barriers?
Um, it's a, it's a kind of a,
an alternative species. A Koala
bear and they hang, you know,
Koala bears and they're hanging out in
trees and they drop on people's heads. Um,
they don't know why, but for some
reason the way Americans talk, they um,
can you get where we're going
with this fucking hate Americans?
I fucking hate America. The
accident. There we go. It's
basically like, well, yeah,
that's the drawback. Gray ones is if
you pull a block on the fuck outta here.
She does a real, yeah. No,
that's real bear with giant fans.
Black, black drop. They only attack
Americans. Australia back Americans.
Are you trying to keep
Americans out of Australia?
We may or may not be doing that. Are
you guys fucking with us? It's a,
I'm not sure. Come on. Are you fucking
with him? I'm not sure if we say anything.
I'm sure when we get back to the,
when we get back to the visa section
at our airport, they may take our past.
How is it possible that these Koala bear,
this shit is Photoshop.
So this is bullshit.
This is bullshit.
There's something about the pitch
and the smell of the American roads.
It's the muscle thing about resumes.
I smell bullshit.
You're smelling the right thing.
Okay.
Why are you bullshitting people
in Australia? In Australia.
It's just a thing. We,
everyone,
every time you had made an American Koala
bears and less homeless,
bloody useless three my life,
they're making little chocolate treats.
So these images with this fake teeth,
it's all, it's a, it's an
Australia target tourists.
Like this girl yesterday, it was
like, no, the terrified, you know,
what about this drop bears? I'm like,
are you serious bits to go online?
You find out in two seconds.
The first,
the first thing when you Google drop
bears is museum of hoaxes. Yeah.
Oh, that's all we got to worry about.
Our pigs are short legs and um,
and pretty much um,
pigs and kangaroos and they're not.
Do you guys eat kangaroo here?
Um, you can get it. Yeah.
I mean you can get it.
You can get it.
Like there's exotic neat places
where they'll say pretty common.
There's a place that serves,
you can buy lion meat that's seen by lion.
I'm going to be fresh.
It's all going to be frozen.
All of it's going to be frozen. But, uh,
there's exotic meat companies like people
are into like trying weird shit like
zebra and stuff like that. I try
go try that zebra like I had, um,
I had a lot of the, the um,
wait til could drive us,
which is like dried sausage and built on,
it's like your jerky but no a zebra.
They've got everything that
they do some really good stuff.
Why not that this is different places
that you can go in Africa where you can
shoot anything you want and uh,
Louis Theroux I had a whole special
about it. It's really quite fascinating.
Did you watch the show?
Yeah. Yeah. By the way,
when you had that podcast I
was geeking out. Cause I, I,
when I hear that guy talk
I just want to hug him.
He's just like such a charming fellow.
He's very cool. He's very interesting too.
I really, really enjoy talking to my mom
loves him. If you're listening to this,
lily, my mum, this is APP Telle loves
you. I love it. That's cool. Yeah.
It was interesting having her Monica,
somewhere along the line I realized
that he was sizing me up to figure out
whether or not he could do a story on me
like Louie was. Yeah, there was, well,
I think he thinks I'm starting
a cult or something like that.
Or you heard you heard
it because he's like,
I have met all these people that tell me
I have to go on the Joe Rogan podcast.
And he's like, they have this thing in
their eye. They look a little crazy.
And he's like,
he's talking to call it like you had
a like this conversation with me.
And I'm like, no man, no. If it's
happening, it's not, I'm not,
it's not me. We had a bunch of
guys sign up to our academy.
They're not there anymore, but they signed
up and they said, they said, um, yeah,
we listen to the Joe
Rogan podcast and he says,
we need to do Jiu Jitsu lift kettlebells
or smoke weed. So these guys would,
they bought kettlebells.
These are it nerds like the dorkiest.
Did you ever seen right?
They bought the kettlebells.
I'm pretty sure they didn't
take them out of the box.
And after training every day they go
smoke weed in their car and like it was
just absolutely what you
prescribed and you'll call,
ah, I'm not prescribing shit,
I'm not running the call.
I just wanted to state that for the record
there is no called stop looking for a
sign up sheet on my website.
It doesn't exist.
But the thing I was going to say about,
which is interesting about the internet,
we were talking about this on
the way here is like in my gym,
each person or has their own kind
of little, ah, okay. So for example,
like most guys listen to your
short right that do martial arts,
but they each tend to diversify.
Like one guy goes, yeah, no,
I'm an institute Rogan anymore into uh, a
Duncan Trussell. He's more kind of like,
you know, my kind of like a
tempo of vibe, you know, like,
and all the kids have now
chosen there their path. Yeah.
It's a cool time to like for content
because everything's free too. Right.
You know, it used to be that if you
wanted different stuff online you,
well first of all was podcast
didn't exist just 10 years ago.
You couldn't find them.
And then second of all like
to have different radio
shows that you listen to her.
It's very difficult to get ahold of cop.
Like I have a bunch of Terence Mckenna
recordings and Alan Watts and a few
different interesting people,
like a few Timothy leary things and
that I've downloaded here and there from
various websites. But you had a
search for him. It was really hard.
We still have a little CD of you like,
and I remember I was saying the
first time we heard your stuff,
it was my friends in high
school and this is like this is,
this is 15 years ago or something,
smoking cigarettes and listen to
this crazy dude on a, on a CD,
talking about little athletes
go to China and stuff.
That was probably like your oldest
stuff, right? Athletes, you know,
like the school teacher comes up to
him and say, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There was a about the Olympics. Yeah,
it was a little bit about little,
it wasn't about Chinese.
It was about messed it up.
That's why you're the comedian.
It was the most about someone going to
the Olympics and then having to go to
high school after they win the gold medal
in the Olympics. Like math. Seriously.
The teachers starts giving him shit
about not doing their homework. Yeah.
But the thing is that your,
your standup,
and probably back in the day like Bill
Hicks and stuff was kind of a dirty
little secret that made me sound
smarter at parties. You know?
And nowadays everybody listens
to podcasts. It's like,
it's, it's, um, it's great,
which is great. Don't get me
wrong. I'm just saying as an, um,
there's no dirty little secret anymore.
Right?
Well that's the thing that people love.
They love knowing things before
it's cool. Yeah. Like, oh,
a new forest mainstream.
It's all bullshit now.
I don't even listen to Rogan anymore.
He's all bullshit.
That's for fucking people that are
just now getting into podcasts.
I am all about Dunkin trust now.
That's what, that's what he's psychic.
Ben does psychic bands like, well, I
can't say bad. Well, you know what?
People will do that.
They'll do that and then they'll be like,
they'll Ben in donkey and after a while
and then they'll go to another guy and
then you bought, but it's fine.
You know? I look, I do that too.
I get in these streaks where I,
I'll get in there a certain podcast and
I'll listen to only hardcore history for
like six months and then
I'll go with radio lab.
I'll just only radio lab for three months.
It's like you get annoyed at people
too if you listen to them too much.
Like I've heard people's like complaining
about me. Yo, you poured crows change.
I used to love it. No training.
No. It's actually hasn't changed.
It's exactly the same.
It just,
you listen to someone after awhile
they become fucking annoying.
That's why marriages
break up. That's why you don't hang out
with the same fucking guy every day,
all day. You get bored with people.
It's fucking, people get annoying, man.
Everything gets annoying if you have,
I love cheeseburgers,
but if I had a fucking cheeseburger,
every dad want to shoot myself every
after a why be like Jesus Christ enough
with the cheeseburgers and
the quality of the day.
The guests has been slowly sinking.
I say this because you guys are here.
I had Eliza slessinger on before you and
she won last comic standing and she's
hilarious. How dare you? Well, you know,
I think one of the keys to the podcast
is that I put people on that I would like
to talk to. Genuine interest is the most
important thing to me and people say, Oh,
you need to have this kind of person
or that are more science people or more
whatever. I don't, I'm not interested.
What I'm interested in is
what I'm interested in.
I'm not interested in diversifying for
anybody else's ideas that way. The, the,
the,
the thing that I talk about is always
something that I'm genuinely fascinated
with and that's all I'm concerned with.
And you've been promoting a lot of people
doing podcasts as in like telling them
to do their own podcast. Sure. Yeah, I
did that with Eliza earlier. I think she,
I think there's plenty of room,
first of all,
there's seven fucking
billion people on the planet,
300 million people in this country,
and the idea that you should only want
people to listen to your podcast is
foolish. And for what I stated before,
you're going to get bored of me. You know?
It's like there should be a lot of the
shit you tune into is plenty of room for
everybody and podcast. Also. I think
the better you get at something,
the more you do it. And when I say the
podcast is the same as it's always been,
I don't necessarily know because I think
I've probably changed as a human being.
I'm evolving, at least I try to constantly
work on myself, so I would hope to,
the podcast gets better,
but along the way you kind
of realize that there's,
there's plenty for everybody, but I'm
like that with everything man. I'm like,
I promote all my friends when
it comes to standup comedy,
when it comes to everything.
I think that the idea of only promoting
yourself or only pushing yourself,
that's a famine mentality and I think
that mentality is a very dangerous
mentality. It's foolhardy. It's,
it's, it's, it's stupid and it, it,
it promotes this sort of
desperate sort of thinking,
which I think goes against the
very nature of a progress itself.
I think it's all about helping people out.
It's all about promoting ideas
that you find beneficial,
promoting people that you enjoy
their work or their, their ideas.
And I think that the more you do that,
the better it is for you and
the better it is for everybody.
Can I see with regard to,
um,
like he's and my friend is starting a
podcast, right? What advice? Well, he,
he, he was writing a book originally
that was the original thing,
but running is not really his
thing. All mine really. Um,
do you think of podcasts is a good place
to start? Fuck yeah. Stuff like that.
Yeah, absolutely. Just do
it. It's not hard. I mean,
you don't need a set up
like this where it's also a,
with hammers and all that shit.
All you need is an MP. Yeah.
You don't need a predator, a lava lamp
or a salt rock. All you need is a,
an MP three recorder and microphones.
It's super easy to do for a couple
hundred bucks. You set it up,
you put it on a table,
you sit around with some chairs
and you talk and you get better.
You do it at first and you know,
you listen to them and you listen
to a input online. That's a big one.
Listened to what people say,
Oh,
you're talking over people too
much or you interrupt too much,
and sometimes people do
things along those lines.
They don't even realize they're
doing it and you have to tell him,
or some people, they just,
they're not listening,
they're just waiting for their turn to
talk. There's a lot of that going on too.
It's funny when you're saying that,
I'm conscious of myself doing that in
terms of other like, okay, hold on. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay. Just hold back. Well,
there's an art to conversation and that's
one of the things you find out about
doing podcasts. You find out
about the art of conversation,
about the find out about the art
of when to talk, when not to talk,
listening actually interacting with people
instead of just trying to say you're
things like there's some people that are
frustrating to do podcasts with because
all they're trying to do is impress upon
you how much they know and spout out
facts and quote people and you're like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Did you even listen to what I said?
You just waited until I was done.
And then you spit out a bunch of quotes
and shit that are not even related.
You know, they're just, they have
this idea that they want to get out.
And a lot of it is like trying to sound
cool. It's a lot of ego. It's a lot.
There's a lot involved that you,
you find these parallels and
just a normal conversation.
I'm shocked sometimes when
I talk to people about,
at how bad people are at not
Inter, uh, at interrupting people,
not listening to people
when they're talking.
So podcasting just makes you
better at the art of conversation.
And the better you get at it,
the less awkward a podcast is to listen
to, you know, so you just do it, man.
Just do it. Start it. You'll get good at
it. So that's the plan. And then hard man,
you guys could do it. You're hanging
here easy. It's, it's easy. You guys are,
you know, you're smart, you're
articulate, you're easy to talk to.
You're down to earth. It's
perfect for a podcast. Set it up.
So it does put a fucking MP, three
recorder, a couple of microphones, Bam.
And you're off to the races.
We did one, we did one on the,
on else that growing downside
and we recorded at 20 times
before he released it.
Why? Because look, we'll
sit in there with my,
with my friend who's a psychologist
and Dylan and I were there and um,
we recorded about 20 before
that and it was just like, man,
it just listen to yourself.
And also on top of that,
like he w he was very concerned
how people would see him as,
as a professional because he's
being open and speaking his mind.
He's a really funny guy. Um, Jonathan,
the [inaudible] Jonathan back,
he's really funny guy,
but he was a bit considered,
it took us about 20 times for him to
stop playing a character. You know,
like the hubcaps slashed Hannibal Lecter.
So you got like some of a trigger
to me it looks like Vince Vaughn.
So he's having a hard time
relaxing and being himself. Yeah,
well that happens.
That happens and that'll,
that'll be taken care of in time.
You just gotta do it.
Just do it after a while.
You get used to it. I mean,
I have friends that sucked at podcasting
in the beginning and now they're
awesome at it and they just,
it just takes time.
You figure out how to do it right.
You figure some people, by the way,
they fucking never get better.
They'll podcast for hundreds of episodes
and they still say stupid shit and jump
in the wrong time and fuck up
the flow of the conversation.
And make it all about them. It's,
it's, you're going to have that too.
You're going to have guests on that are
disasters that you never going to have
on again. And you recognize
that like while you're
talking to them like, oh fuck,
I can never have this guy. And
again, some people just not design,
some people are just not
fucking interesting. You don't
even know why. Like what,
what is it about one person's
personality that makes them fascinating?
I don't know. Is it honesty? Is it their,
their curiosity? Is it, what is it,
you know, I don't know what
he's got a different thing.
Sometimes I would talking before about
like some people were talking about what
and meanwhile I've just talked over him
for the whole podcast supportive here.
I want to, no, no you did. No, that's
cool. Well, you guys are all interacting.
It's no, it's cool.
But the thing was like,
sometimes it's kind of feels like
people aren't ready to hear some stuff,
you know, like in terms of,
um, holding back, you know,
and I wonder if that comes across
as boring when you're trying to,
do you know what I mean?
Like we talked about some of this stuff.
Some of your stories is like maybe not
for, I dunno, you know what I mean?
Like it might come across as not being
willing to share, you know what I mean?
Oh, I don't think so. You
can't overthink things either.
You got to just put it out and
then listen to the feedback,
listen to it yourself.
But sometimes it's hard to see yourself
the way other people see you, you know,
you, you have to, and then it's also,
you're gonna, it's gonna be hard,
listened to the feedback because punching
people are going to writeZ , Z, Z, Z,
Xie fucking boring. Kill yourself. You
mean it's going to be a lot of that.
You're going to have to deal with that.
Parents,
your own parents know you're going to
have to deal with that. But listen,
I would think that just your
stories about Thailand, I mean,
just the story that you were telling me
about those dealing with those bodies,
just that alone,
like holy shit,
he's telling me, you were telling me
the dice. Tell me about the aiding.
Remember we were told
about any of this stuff.
I'm at the store has a lot of
them, you know, funny to me,
like have a Jewish background.
For example, I never ate pork.
It was just what we did it.
And that's a part of my religion.
But like now it can't
stop here. Um, you know,
we'll transporting bodies off.
I'm on one boat and would sit in the
middle making sure nobody's jumped off the
side or fell off the side and they'd
would transport food back onto the island
without cleaving anything.
Food Day there'd be flies.
And it was pretty bad. Holy Shit.
I was starving. I was like, Nah,
we get an 80 wheel vomiting a lot just
from the smells and stuff. I was like,
you know, let's, um, you know, I need to,
I need some food, man. I've got eight now.
So I went over there, I'm
like, what is this packet?
There's just like flies everywhere. Might
not fuck that. I'm not, not even that.
And then I said, no, I've got
to eat something. So I had,
it's just a little packet and an $80
like this stuff is freaking awesome.
So I sit to the type person, I'm like,
like near right, like what is this?
And like our Ni, Ni Mu something he
moved or like it must be a cow, right?
Some 80 of his stuff.
And a man,
I got so addicted to it that I got them
to write it down in English and Thai for
me. And then when I went to back
to the main land and for many,
many trips after I kept ordering
the same dish, I loved it.
And my friend turns around and he goes,
[inaudible] when to eat pork? I'm like,
it's not pork, it's Mu, it's
Catholic. Moo Cow. He's ties,
probably looked to me like, oh, this
white guy. And I was like, Oh, you know,
they're just making their sound. An animal
that Lou actually translate to pork.
So, I mean, eating pork
for like 10 years, it,
even though it was pork and it was just
so much miscommunication and translation
problems,
there's lots of,
so you still thought that you were
adhering to your religious practice?
Um, look, I probably would have
ended anyway and like, you know,
the prongs and stuff, but um, it was
so good, man. I've never given it up.
I love it.
Yeah. Prawns are against
the shell fish. Right?
And that's supposed to eat shellfish.
Jews love the unlimited shrimp. A buffet.
So yeah, pretty much. It's true. That's
hilarious. It shrimp gets a pass,
but it's just a cloven hoof.
You ever had wild pork?
We hunted but never ate. You can't eat
it in Australia. Why not? It's the worms.
They're pretty gross.
So they tend the babies,
they capture the babies and they deworm
them and send them to Germany because
they love the boys.
You know,
I didn't know balls were pigs for the
first one or watch Abelick's asterix and
Obelix. I was like, boars, I
didn't have bars. What pigs?
They'll like this mythical
creature. Well, it's,
apparently it's all the same
species. I had a guy, uh,
is the guy that I hunt with that's been
on the podcast is named Steve Rinella
book. Yeah. Great Book.
But he said it's all,
they're all from the genus Seuss
Grapha they're all the same thing.
Is that a wild pig can breed with a,
a domestic pig that sort of,
they're all pigs. There's a thing
about pigs that happens too.
When you take a domestic pig
and they get loose in the wild.
Within three weeks their
body starts to change.
They metamorphosize their,
their,
their hair gets longer and thicker
and bushier their tusks grow.
Their nose grows.
Really fascinating stuff from him
telling me that's what I said, Mike,
you sound smarter.
Potties [inaudible] I'm like fuck up
and get away with anything anymore.
They morph.
It's really fascinating.
They'd look physically different
than the pigs that you have.
Like in domestic stables. They changed
their appearance. Their nose grows longer,
but it's really weird. They get tusks.
Yeah. And that's a domestic pig.
They start to look like the Lord as
well. Huge, huge problem. Huge problem.
We can hug is, yeah, there's no
tag limits on them in California.
And you could shoot as many as you want,
man. You could go shoot pigs all day.
So he'll say, I can't do it man. But
he likes he can't shoot pigs. No,
I just got in in Australia.
Don't should pigs. You Dog. Um Oh. And
then you stab him. I can't do that.
But we've got,
depends where you are in New South Wales,
but you can kill pigs and Kangaroos
if they're destroying the land.
But you're going to stand like skippy
skippy back in the day. The Bush,
kangaroo skippy the Bush kangaroos.
Like he's,
he was kinda like Mister Ed was like
alien, Mister Red. He didn't talk,
but he was kind of that character. Like,
you know, he's a good guy. Wrestling.
He was pretty much like captain America
about as interesting. Like he's the, like,
he was basically like a hero
that didn't really do anything.
Say anything too interesting. Or You
like Captain America? I find a doll,
but I know it's so skewed.
Anyway. So skippy skippy,
that's given me, so it's
like lassie. It'd be,
oh man,
can I tell you something?
You haven't seen
something very Australian.
So when we go hunting and the farmers
want to kill the Kangaroos really hard for
us cause it's like, cause it's kids grew
up with skippy. We grew up with skippy.
There's some kangaroos that are bigger,
right?
There's a red ones and the gray
ones, the red ones are scary. Yeah.
How big they get Taronga Zoo in
Sydney. Which by the way, if you ever,
did you go to yes.
Yes.
Why would see Kangaroos in the wild?
This big massive.
They're the ones we see a small, if you
hit one like a kangaroo people, oh Geez.
You know, people would talk
about Kangaroos like God,
he's so cute and this and that.
And they are cute.
They tasted really good as
well. But you know, like they,
they are the roads everywhere. And you
know, why don't kill wasn't even longer.
It was like two, three months ago,
you're reading the newspaper. Um,
kangaroo went cause they jumped
in front of you. Like, Dr not as,
you know, they jump a lot higher but,
and they look at the headlights like, oh,
what's this? And then boom, he
hit them. But what happens is, um,
they, it went through, because the
way they're built like, you know,
did like he'd hits it rolls over the car.
Where's this kangaroo with through the
windshield at the very bottom front to
back and killed the kid in the back.
Oh God. So like, you know, we, we,
you see them everywhere
on the road. Wombats and
Kangaroos out about a year ago.
One try to jump through the
window while we were driving.
We don't personally hunt Kangaroos,
but it's that you can do it in a certain
area. There's just too many of them.
It gets board. The one thing I
was going to say, I don't know,
Americans probably haven't
seen this and it's theirs.
There was a bit of a legal
thing going on in Australia,
but it just reminds me of skippy.
There's a show called home and away.
You've seen him in a way it was very
popular in England. I've heard of it.
I've never seen anybody get nine
or to an Irish thing anyway.
There's this very wholesome character
called Alpha. Have you seen this? You can,
you can swear on your podcast. Okay.
It's a serious load of swearing off.
I can do this. True, but
it's a second nature.
But if we can get 'em taming the load
up, alf, Ms Not Alpha, like the alien.
This is Alpha is like a,
uh,
like a wholesome sorta fatherly character
on a small town show that everyone
likes. Right? And, and what kind of
animal is he? He's not an animal,
but he is in this,
we're going to show you.
So there was this whole
thing in Australia. What
happened? Was He, um, Jamie,
the name of it so he can go and
look up alf Mr Doodle Burger.
So basically what happened was that
guide took all existing home in a waste
stuff and he dubbed over it and made
Alpha into this character who's basically
like, I'm a serial killer slash murderer
rapist that loves like Colombian,
like a little Colombian lawyers.
And now it's been quoted all over,
but it ended up on the news because
they tried to sue the guy. Yeah, that's,
that's kind of a douchey thing to do,
but it is hilarious.
And we have to show you because the
Americans didn't know what we're talking
about. You know, we didn't have
Hollywood. Okay. This is one of them.
That's how, what's the
music? Oh, is this sound
okay? Just a video. Well,
Americans, we don't,
we don't really have too many
of those videos available.
Probably try and look up Alf.
And it's really important you have to
see it because it's a very Australian
Alpha awards awards ceremony and it
caused a lot of problems in Australia
controversy and basically your average
Australian quotes it all the time.
But Americans have no idea. And they quote
this video, this video. So ridiculous.
So ridiculous. Wow. I, I'm,
I'm trying to judge whether you've
got the patients for it right now.
I'm not sure. But you do have to see it.
It's, it's, uh, now look up, look up.
So you can never kill a kangaroo.
Basically.
You'd never can because the guys would
go with do and they eat it and stuff like
that. Can we put the
vibe? Oh wait, is this it?
I'll tell you though,
in the real thing.
Which instead of the fake thing,
no, I don't think this is it.
Okay. I'll Twitter it to you guys.
Check it out because it's outrageous.
So, um, you, you couldn't shoot,
you couldn't do the pig hunting
thing because of the way they do it.
Where they sick dogs. I'm an insta
habit dogs and they stab at it.
That's a real common way to do it.
The country boys are a bit desensitized
to it and then a real nice dude,
you know as well. They're nice guys. But
um, I don't feel like that's thing I,
yeah,
that's a weird way to do it.
Holding it down with a dog and then
stabbing in the neck. You know,
you can shoot dangerous there. You
sure is. But why don't they shoot him?
You can't say like with
the terrain it's quite,
it's quite hard to follow the dogs.
So then one of their dogs,
it's different types of
why they using two dogs.
So they normally would sniff them out
and he'd get the running with the dog.
You don't want to use the garden case.
He shut the door.
So is it just such a dense terrain
that you can't find them any other way?
Generally? I mean, look, it's,
it's, I was against it and
then I, I went to the farms,
I was hanging out with the guys
and they, you know, like anything,
they've got their own logic and you
know, and, and it makes
sense the own rationale.
The rationale is look at costs us a
hundred grand last year and you know,
it's basically like,
look,
we're growing food for people and they're
destroying it so therefore we kill
them.
Well,
they're very different than any other
animal and they're also very smart and
they breed all year round to help many
litters of many pigs all year round.
It's just a, they have a huge problem
with it. In America, especially in Texas.
Texas is so bad that they've allowed
them to start shooting them out of
helicopters when machines.
Have you seen that as something fucked up?
Pull up a pig man and Ted Nugent.
Uh,
it's a a pork lips now. Fuck though. Yeah.
They sit on a fucking helicopter
and they fly over these. Well,
these places are literally
infested with pigs.
They have so many pigs in these farms and
they destroy millions of dollars worth
of crops every year.
There's a least 5 million pigs in Texas.
You've also got that.
I'm show where those hot chicks and the
fake boobs running around catching pigs.
One point $5 billion in damage per year.
I'll put 5 billion. Yeah, 1.5
billion. I mean, that's incredible.
See, that's the thing. Americans
get these machine guns.
We've got bolt actions and see that guy?
That's pig man.
Pig Man has a show where he just shoots
pigs all year round. That's Ted Nugent.
He's an American patriot.
Yeah. Can I ask you,
do you think someone can do
this and be well balanced,
like as a person to do what? No, I'm
not talking about like just hunting.
I mean as in like
hardcore animal slaughter.
Um, well, you know, it depends on
what you're doing it for. I mean,
what these people are
doing with this, uh, uh,
pork lips now video where they're
shooting them out of helicopters.
They actually have to eradicate
these pigs from these farms.
They are growing in population
at a staggering rate and
they can't control them.
They, they have no other options
other than hiring a hunter.
So they have companies that they
hire to have people come in and uh,
and shoot these pigs.
They bring people on and they
give the meat to families.
No, no, no, no, no. The hunters for the
hungry. Look, they're just delicious.
The meat is fantastic.
I shot a wild pig a few months
back and I made a ham recently. I,
I Brian this ham for six days
and it smoked it for a day.
It's delicious. I mean, it was so good.
I'm going to do it again
in a couple of weeks.
I have another ham and a
couple of shoulders. You guys
do delicious. We, we, we,
we do, we do barbecue.
Well, but we, you guys are,
I went to Kansas and Kansas
Barbecue is legit. Kansas City.
Yeah. There, what's the one
they got that popular like, um,
or don't know the name of it.
There's a bunch of really good the city,
but I've never heard of, you guys
have got a deep culture of food here.
I, it's, it's uh, we just,
I was, he was a bit simple
at that steak on the barbecue acts.
This is no joke to,
you want to get some barbeque
pig and taxes. This pork man,
this pig man guy pork man pig man
has a show now called boss Hog.
He just likes and it's all about his,
uh,
he has a barbecue place
and he shoots the pigs,
then brings him to the barbecue place
and they serve these wild pigs that they
barbecue. Sounds awesome. So
good. It's so healthy for you too.
Yeah. They're much healthier
animals. They're wild pigs.
This is a dark meat. And they had
this campaign in America called pork,
the other white meat. And they
would show like pork is white meat.
That's unhealthy pork like right. If
the pork is white, it's like anemic.
It's like veal. Pork, like
wild pork is dark. It's like a,
a deeper red or color. Have you had
it? I haven't had it. It's really good.
I have to make sure you cook it all the
way through because the trick and osis
cause I'm tricking gnosis comes from
animals eating other animals that have
trick analysis.
So these animals could possibly get it
from like a rats or rabbits or you know,
anything else they eat.
They eat a lot of big deer babies.
They ground eggs like at ground laying
birds eight 88 we've caught when eating
each other. Oh yeah, they'll eat
anything. Their animals, pigs are,
they're smarter shit too. They see common.
They see you, they hear you, they smell,
you know, they fucking bolt. We so
are we. So on one of the farmers,
there was a whole family and he went to
shoot at them and the two adult pigs ran
one direction and the kids
ran in the lineup and escaped.
And obviously that didn't talk to each
other and planet, but it was brilliant.
That's funny. Yeah. It looked like it
looked almost plan while they are there,
smartest dogs, they're
smart, you know, their trick.
Tricky animals and delicious
and delicious Australians.
We kill them and then we
shipped them off to jail.
I need people are smart enough to eight.
The ties it Paul,
I didn't know about that it worm thing
that you guys can Xeloda webs of the
Kangaroos as well. Six as well.
Categories. Cheap meat for us. You know,
like what does it taste like?
It's very gay,
but you gotta know how to cook
up properly. Yeah, it's um,
it's not the nicest meat,
but it's 99% fat free.
Oh, I'm sure. It's probably very
lean. Oh, the strong lifters,
it's promoted to them as
really kangaroo meat like that.
I worry because they basically, they
kill it and then refrigerate it. They,
they ha let's not, um, fresh. It's, well,
they killed it and they put it in the
thing, but I, it's not like bread,
you know what I mean? It's
like, you know, it's some fun.
It's some hunter on a farm killing
Chucky and I didn't really know what the
process is of it's not bread.
What do you mean?
You mean like as in there's no fobs with
kangaroos where they kill, you know,
give it health checks and then
kill it and then produce it.
I'm not saying that's better or
worse. I just mean as in, you know,
it shows up in your Woolworth's, what
do you guys have? I'm not walnuts.
You guys have like Metro or,
uh,
but um,
I kind of think
like, you know, where, how well is this,
did they have a department of agriculture
or anything like that? They did.
They checked them spectrum.
I'm sure that you couldn't sell it.
My friends who are professional Terry,
who we go to the farm lot,
it's got a little Thai boxing gym out
there and we go be going there for a
couple of years and he was a professional
hunter for a long time and he's like,
yeah, bull riders who got me into it.
And he turned around and it's like, man,
I've never eat kangaroo. Like I'd been
shooting these things since I was a kid.
He said, man, if you saw what was
in them like and how we did it,
you probably wouldn't eat it.
Now that's only one person was,
a lot of them had worms,
but it might just be that check
might just be that in the area.
I don't know how he got on this topic
so much, but it's a good topic. Pigs,
kangaroos.
The thing is,
funny enough I was saying or doing
when we went out to the farm, you know,
I'm very conscious of my diet. I'm
sure you guys are too, you know. Um,
we went out to the farm,
the farm boys, they,
they tend to not really think about diet.
So they'll eat red meat sometimes and a
red ball and that's all they'll eat for
three days. Vegetables. I mean,
they do obviously sit down and have
a meal here and there, you know?
But we went out there and Dylan,
I was sitting there and we bought our
suppliers in our little bag and you know,
we had our snacks and our this and that
and we were eating all the time eating
all the time. Right? And the
boys didn't really eat much.
And after a while we realized we
were eating because we're anxious,
we're not used to having nothing to do
and we're just automatically pull out a
bar and just start eating it,
you know?
And after a while we just
started doing what the boys did.
And I started thinking,
man, I'm going to get sick.
I'm going to feel gross and feel
unhealthy. But after a couple of days,
I started to realize like,
I think we put a bit too much emphasis
on what we eat because we ate red meat
straight for four days almost.
And we had a little bit of this and that.
And because we weren't eating a lot of it,
we actually felt quite healthy.
Like as an our body adapted to kind
of just doing what we were doing.
I was really concerned. I was
like, man, I don't feel queasy,
I'm going to get constant,
you know like all that sort of stuff.
But when you're out there and you're
doing and you're just eating it,
it seems like maybe we overemphasize
veggies. No, I don't think so.
It's certainly not a balanced diet.
I mean you could get away with it for a
few days if you took that on for several
months.
He probably traditional deficiencies.
Think the funniest thing was like first
time what my brother up there and I've
got like my jacket on and I've got like
ammunition and I've got my nice survival
kit, bandage for snakes and I'm
like pulling it out to check.
I've got everything by tortures.
Liam pulls out a,
he pulls out a sandwich bag with salad.
I can't eat without salary. You, you're
trying to impress the farm boys man.
You bring him a salad. I bought my
own vegetables cause I was like,
I can't eat meat without much loss,
you know,
crocodile bag of salad and my cucumber.
Some layers.
How long did that stuffs they good for?
Oh we had a call for like three days
or something, you know. But anyway,
it's just one of those
things where their diet you,
my body just adapted to whatever I'd
have to do. You know? That's interesting
man. I would think that after
awhile your body would go dickhead.
He need a fucking salad or to love money
tokens three days up about three days.
Four days. You'd be fine. Three or four
days he'd be fine. I felt good actually.
Weirdly,
I dunno,
it was just what I was eating a lot
less than I normally would in the city.
Like at eat, little pieces of meat,
they'd kill and barbecue and eat it.
And what kind of meat was it
again? It was rabbit, rabbit, deer.
Just getting really healthy, wild
game. Red Rabbit is out of control.
There's so much vitamins
and so much nutrition in,
in wild game too because they're eating
wild grasses and wild plants that are
just filled with natural nutrients.
This rabid, rabid, sexually.
One of the best things I've ever made
and I was a bit disappointed by deer,
but yeah, really good man. How are
you disappointed with deer? It was,
look we didn't,
you got to stand like we didn't hang it
properly and all that sort of like Yo
guys is I'll ideas a week.
Cost is, you know what I mean?
Like Australia's animals are a little
bit wake. It don't really weighty.
They're not really meeting anyway cause
it's just my opinion. That's interesting.
Some farm is going to punch me in,
but you don't know shit about Dhea,
but it's not common to get DNA.
We were in Canada and there was deer
on the side of the road. Walking sale.
I'll walk in. Oh yeah. You can get that
all over the place. Well certain places,
like in Pennsylvania,
there's certain parts of Pennsylvania
where they change their deer hunting
season to all year round.
They just let people shoot them because
they're fucking everywhere and they use
a, they have a bow season like all year
round and they do it in these areas that
are like suburban areas. There was a
show on it and on hunting shows. Yup.
Cause guys set up on,
I mean it was like these estates,
these beautiful homes that have these
giant pieces of property in like 2030
acres and they had fucking so many deer
hitting cars or cars hitting deer rather
deers eating people's lawns and
all kinds of shit. D eating.
There are gardens rather eating the roses
that they brought in these a hunters
to set up tree stands in these
suburban neighbors. That's crazy.
They're all equivalent as a case for us
because we'd love to find deer and shit.
We'd have a fun day or so. It's pretty
hard to find. People think we're nuts.
That's a funny thing. He's the
biggest animal lover you've ever bet.
He's got this big dog.
Ralphie loves those works for like dog
charities and animal charities and then
he goes hunting. Yeah. Well,
people have a hard time with the
idea of cruelty and rightfully so.
I mean I think people are scared that
people are hunters are evil people that
want to kill animals. But the
reality is if you're wearing leather,
you're killing animals.
You might not do it with your own hand,
but you're doing it.
You're sitting in a chair right now that's
covered in murdered animals, guests.
I've had vegans sitting that was very
chairs that you said it again, rest there,
but on, on murdered cows. You know
the shoes you wear, the belt you wear.
And then on top of that, if you buy
organic vegetables and you think you're,
you're away from your heels,
they fucking run machines over those
vegetables to collect them and they're
chopping up a lot of rabbits, a lot
of mice. The more animals are killed,
more animals are killed per pound of
vegetables that are killed per pound of
meat. A hug. What?
What is it about vegans that we'd
just love pissing off a Taser and man,
it says something about, well there's
self righteous and there's also this,
this moral high ground that they
like to take and not all of them.
Some of them are super cool.
I've met a lot of really cool vegans,
but some of them are really fucking
annoying and they want to tell you that
they're better than you because
they're Vegan and they want to,
they're proselytizing to, they're always
trying to get other people to be Vegan.
And this just by the way, this straight
Vegan diet, not that healthy. Yeah,
I'm divorced. Diet is a better diet,
you know, and I'm divorced also.
You can eat shit like eggs that have
no animal cruelty attached to him
whatsoever. I have organic eggs
cause I have chickens that are pets.
I picked my chickens up.
Yeah, I have 14 chickens.
I could pick them up and hold them and
they give me eggs every day as my left.
That's what he wants to do as my left.
And there's no cruelty involved at all.
I mean they lay eggs every day.
They don't have,
I mean there's no potential whatsoever
that egg ever becoming a chicken.
The only way that egg can become a
chicken as if you have a rooster,
so we only have hens, so the hands
hanging out. They have a good time.
They have a big yard to run around on and
they eat bugs and worms and everything
they find in in grass as well.
And then also we give them chicken food.
That's a healthy actual chickens. No,
you wouldn't kill it. I would, yeah.
I almost killed one of them. One of
them peck my daughter in the face and I,
I came real close.
My wife was like that little bitch.
She did it again and I was like,
all right, let's do it. I was ready.
I was just trying to figure
out how to do it. I had to,
I was going online and it was almost
like the chicken figured out that we were
going to fuck it up and it completely
backed off of all of its aggressive
behavior. It's like a totally felt
the vibe. It was really weird, man.
It's like I was seconds away. I bought
an ax, I was ready to rock and roll.
I was completely ready to, uh, to
cook this chicken up. I'd love,
I've innovated the fresh
chicken like that. I, I,
well I was assumed that it's a lot like
other things that you are organic and
fresh.
They just taste better.
The eggs taste way better
when you eat organic fresh
eggs. They just, they're the,
first of all, the Yolk is very dark.
It's a dark orange. It's just healthier.
It's very healthy. I ate seven of
them this morning. Yeah. Seven. Yeah.
I eat them all. I six, seven eggs a day.
Yeah. Hit Him all the time. You know,
the funny thing is we were
forced vegetarians for the first
is what do your family want you to be?
But Dad was big into karate and you know,
like the credit guys that have this kind
of like, they follow different, you know,
like the catch onto a set philosophy
and he's whole thing made sense.
It was just about full words.
Now look, he just, you know,
he thought he read all these books and
there was no internet back then. And, um,
you know, he had this idea that you
know, too many hormones in the meat,
which he's right,
you've been to Brazil and have you
ever seen a chicken breast in Brazil?
It's about the size of this
table. You know, like it's,
and you see all these homeless dudes
walking around and they look like they're
bodybuilders.
But you know what's interesting,
there's a misconception about
chicken breasts and it really is,
I'm not that they pump
them up with hormones.
Cattle is what they use hormones on,
but chickens, it's just breeding, right?
Just bread, larger breasted
chickens until they, they, you know,
only genetically select the
larger breasted chickens.
And to the point where these chickens,
they're so large breasted that they
can't fly. You know, chickens can fly,
they don't fly for very long,
but they can fly for short distances.
Like my chickens, they have roosts
and they can jump up to the roost.
They flub them about when they fly up,
up to the roof and then sit there.
But these chickens aren't going nowhere.
They're fucking giant fat, tits chickens.
And, but it's, it's genetic
selection more than, than hormones.
Not that chickens haven't
been shot up with hormones
before. Right. With chickens,
it's more antibiotics that they have to
deal with because they're on top of each
other and they getting sick all the time
and they're also feeding them chicken.
It's like they're feeding chickens,
chickens,
they're feeding them chicken shit and
chicken heads and chicken assholes.
If you feed him healthy diet,
the omnivorous diet that
a regular chicken eats,
you get healthier and you get healthier
animals. Yeah, I feed them only grass.
I mean they,
my chickens eat natural things like that.
They find when they go out and pack and
they forage in is I have a big yard and
they run around the yard and they kill
bugs and stuff and then we feed them.
We also feed them table scraps, so they
eat like beef. They'll eat, they'll eat.
They'll, they've eaten deer before I fed
them pork, right? They do. Yeah. Yeah.
They approached me and he do. When you
go home in Thailand, like there's no,
you don't see a lot of chicken.
It's chicken and the food,
but it's mainly for Westerners.
But the ties will have their own chickens.
What do they do with them? They go
fighting chickens, chickens on TV.
It's it behind so no one can see, you
know, like oh quick, someone's coming in.
The white people would come in like put
in your cage, like shoving it aside.
They're not the ones that the hooks on
there, just like kickboxing, kickboxing,
chicken flush as well.
I have a friend who, uh,
who does that well, he's a friend, he's a,
he's a friend of a friend and he has a
a hundred chickens in his backyard and
he's from Mexico. You know, he, he
barely speaks English. I don't know why,
but that makes sense. And all of
his friends are from Mexico too.
And it's kind of interesting. He, he, uh,
he got in trouble for killing a goat
and cooking it in his yard because he
butchered the goat in his yard and there
they were upset at him for doing that.
And, uh, he didn't understand cause he's,
you know, he's from Mexico and he's like,
he goes, but, but you eat
meat. Like if you eat meat,
like what do you care where the,
how the animal gets killed.
I can't kill it in my yard. Like, and he,
you know, they, they're told him like,
there's all these regulations. You can't
just kill a goat in your yard. He's like,
okay, what do I have to do? I had to
bring it somewhere to kill it. Like crazy.
Why can't I just kill it here? There's
a lot of room. I just kill his goat.
Do you think we kind of lost that?
It's a weird thing. Like my, my,
my wife slash girlfriend weft now,
I'll be ready for like two weeks ago.
I got married two days
before we went overseas,
so she went on a honeymoon to Italy
and I went, I went, I went to Canada.
So I actually haven't seen her since
then or it's just really random, but,
but her mum can kill
a chicken and cook it up, like
you wouldn't believe. Right. Um,
she's there from a Vietnamese,
she's, she's Aussie, but
her mom's Vietnamese. Right.
My grandma, and I'm sure your
grandparents could kill a chicken skin it,
they'd be, you know, make 40 dishes with
it. They'd use the fat, the skin there.
My Dad was telling me, well, our
whole family die of heart disease.
The oldest one's like 62 and he was
showing their favorite dish was you'd take
all the leftovers, put on a pan, fry
it, skin bones, everything. Right.
You'd fry them till it liquefies and then
you pour it into a bottle and then dip
it in. Nice. And then you take it and
you just wipe it on your bread. Ah, okay.
Amazing.
Yeah. Well like a pod tay or something
like that. Well, like a fat pet. Hey,
but hmm.
Then you're saying it was his grandma
and his, they're like whole generation.
They wouldn't have a problem with just
skin. It use every part of its body,
you know,
that's, that's the lost. The reason
why people don't like hunting,
although they do eat meat. I have friends
that eat meat and we'll never hunt.
They wouldn't do it. He
couldn't do it. I'm like,
I understand you don't want to be cruel.
I don't understand.
And I understand that they
enjoy that separation.
But to criticize people who
don't enjoy that separation,
I think it's kind of crazy. It's
a, there's a weird disconnect,
but there's a lot of people that eat
meat and have eaten meat and don't have a
problem with ordering a cheeseburger,
but it really looked down on people
that hunt. I think it's the ease.
I think it's not the easiest
way obviously, but I think
it's the easiest on your,
the ethical dilemma is the easiest because
you're, you're dealing with an animal.
Like that deer right there had no idea
a human being was even a thing until it
sauce. And then it was dead
moments later. You know,
I shot that deer in the middle
of the forest in Montana. I mean,
that fucking deer was living in the
wild country of Montana and it was
delicious.
And I had no problem with it.
I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
And the idea that somehow or
another it's okay to, to eat a cow,
but it's not okay to do that. And
then other people will tell you, oh,
buy only organic grass fed dear.
Let me tell you. Or grass fed cows.
Let me tell you something about that.
I have a friend who keeps organic grass
fed cows and those mother fuckers are
terrified. You go near them, they run,
they run and they all huddle up together.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because they know that they're going
to die and they know someone's going to
shoot them and eat them. Like this idea
that if you eat organic grass fed cows,
you're somehow or another were removed
from the cruelty. Yeah, they aren't,
they aren't kept in a pen.
They aren't jammed into some pig box like,
like pigs are. And they do run
around free and they do eat grass,
but they're fucking shit in their pants.
Anytime a person
we, we, we did some, um, city
boys did some cow herding man.
Northern is that fucking terrifying if
you're in a pin with these cows? I mean,
they don't attack humans, but they're the
big, if you've ever been in a passive,
cows are big animals. Just crazy
bitches drag riding on them. The males,
remember I was like the first one I
was like, he did, he did a job done,
messed around and jumped on a cow too.
There's a whole bunch of buck like
bowls do not use the old ones,
but that will run each other into a corner
and kill each other. Like, you know,
like this is so silly though, will
they're very big. Would you eat dog?
Would I love dogs?
Um,
if I was in another country and uh,
maybe it was like for a television show
or something like that and they were
serving dog like fee effect, I would
have a real hard time with it. Still.
I might do it just to see what it
tastes like and just to, you know,
if I was over someone's home and they
offered it to me and it was a part of
their culture,
I don't think that I would insult
them and say that I wouldn't eat it.
And if I eat pig,
I mean pig and dog are
supposed to be like a dog,
supposed to be actually as intelligent
or more, or excuse me, a pig.
It's supposed to be as intelligent
or more than a dog. Yeah.
So it'd be a bit hypocritical.
But I have a deep connection with dogs.
I've had dogs my whole life and I have
two dogs now and I love dogs. I love him.
Seven people. This guy sat me down for
intervention cause you ain't gotta go.
Yeah, I've got a massive French
mastiffs. I love it. It's $2,000 a week,
but it's a lot.
Had He ogs an investment.
Yeah, I have a massive to do you have a
regency mastiff? If it's a little smaller,
they're, they're, uh,
like 120, 140 pounds.
This guy goes up to about 90
kilograms. What's that? 200 pounds.
It's a big boy. It's a big dog, but
he had a lot of joint problems. Right?
Those poor dogs. Yeah. My mind starting
to get a little arthritis in his hips.
Not Bad. He goes, me and he's, he runs and
what was the very slobbery? The
sweetest dogs ever. Yeah. My, my,
my dog is like so great with my kids.
You know,
they go over and grab his face and kiss.
He's got no anger in him.
The regency massive was raised to,
uh, to have no human aggression.
Sweet dogs, no dog aggression
either. They're real good.
Great with other dogs too.
What was the wedding
dimension? Intervention.
I'm not allowed to put up,
put up to eight dog pictures.
The problem is right boys
back home typically to get
your dog even bid should in
this show. Of course. Yeah. They're going
to be like, oh, you mentioned Ralph.
It is a weird thing, right? You love dogs,
but you also love hunting
dog assessed with dogs.
Well,
there's a bond that humans have with
dogs and especially that's a thing that
people don't understand that dogs and
hunting have gone hand in hand forever.
One of the reasons why we have such a
tight bond with dogs in the first place is
that dogs were used not
just to keep animals away,
like keep the wolves away from camps,
but to help people hunt.
He was devastated when we were in Vietnam.
They serve just some starters
and afterwards we didn't
know what they were and
he discovered he didn't
his man's best friend.
So that took about a year or two tasted
funny. It didn't taste right. It was,
but this kind of explain it. This guy
is like comes, he retired from fighting.
So the first thing he does is replaced
fighting with pictures of dogs.
It's like we're running a business,
you know what I mean? Like put some
pictures of your tattoos up
with something and you know,
like not the fucking dog actually did I
actually, I was like, Look Dylan, listen,
you know, like, you know you love Moitai.
I get that. But you've got to understand,
people want to see it.
Thai boxer that's got a little bit
of like book book book out about him,
you know,
and you know it's him and it's that bloody
[inaudible] with his tattoo and look
into six pack and stuff. Right? This
guy's with fucking slobbery dog runner.
You know, like I'm like, okay, you're
allowed one picture or a week Instagram.
The rest of the winter face never set any
rules. And I said, the restaurant Moy,
Tai, I don't want to use these
fucking around with business. Well,
why don't you just do it
on your personal account?
They're kind of the same thing.
It's all interconnected.
It's Instagram and he's got his
own Instagram and it's hot dogs.
The dog goes, Ron loves Ralphy. Yeah,
I love dogs too.
I love animals.
That's something that people
have a weird problem with,
but they don't have a weird problem with
loving animals and then feeding their
animals.
Animals.
Like I have friends who fucking are
vegans and they have cats and I'm like,
do you under fucking stand
that cats only eat meat?
It's not like a dog. A dog can
eat carrots, a dog can eat grains.
Got dogs eat rice.
Like if I have a friend who cooks
for his dog and that happen,
he gets his dog ground beef and mixes
it with potatoes and rice and it's
delicious. You do that for your dog.
Cool. It's good. Probably herself,
but you can't do that with a
cat if you can do with the cat.
It has to be just animal protein.
That's it.
That's the only thing that
cat is allowed to eat. Yeah.
You can't feed cats grains.
Cats are not supposed to eat rice
that's supposed to eat carrots.
Cats eat fish and they eat chicken and
the beef and they liver and they eat.
They eat animal protein. They're
carnivores, their straight carnivores.
So for you to be a Vegan and have
a fucking cat living in your house,
like you're involved in the killing of
animals, whether you like it or not,
I mean, I guess there's probably some
Vegan cat food, but I can't imagine it.
Let's go kill that right now. Probably
kill the cat. It's probably not good.
Vegan cat food bad.
Let's,
let's look up fat cat bat.
That's one of my two flybys
cats. Okay. Vegan cat food. Know.
I just would imagine that shit is not
good. That's basically mini lines.
Oh look, it says actually, and the Vegan
cat foods contained adequate amounts.
Is it okay to raise a cat and Vegan?
I think it's hilarious,
by the way. I think that
is fucking hilarious. Now,
artists into activists with more than
one field on the family and Ithaca,
New York, more in her partner, Shariah
Golding. That means they're lesbians.
What a surprise lesbian vegans with cats,
that's crazy. You never hear about that.
Relatively small,
but deeply dedicated group of Vegan pet
owners who believe their cats and dogs
die as she reflect their own beliefs
about the treatment of animals and the
environmentally sustainable,
sustainable lifestyles.
Is it okay to give your diet of
spare me all the Foa, outrage,
outrage of the billions of land,
animals and trillions of sea animals
tortured and killed each year in the u s
alone for food to feed people and
pets? I don't know, man. You know,
you leave a cat outside that
cat's gonna kill a bird. That,
that's sweet kitty cat that
you have as a murderer. Yeah.
My cat makes these crazy noises.
When he looks outside,
he sees like something like a squirrel.
His whole jaw starts, he start,
their jaws start moving up and down.
Like they can't help it.
Like they just thinking about biting. I
till, have you ever had a fight? Dreams?
Like what? You wake up kicking, you
know, you know those dreams? Well,
cats have those when they
see a fucking animal,
if they want to kill because
it's like that. They have reflux,
they make noises.
He's just looks out the window.
Have you ever watched
them like stalk a stalk,
stoke your leg and then watch a lion?
There's very little difference.
You're like a lion crawling through the
grass or a cat crow in three. A kaput.
Yeah. Look, they look identical. Oh yeah,
absolutely identical. They're murderers,
bro. They are fucking
murderers apparently. Um,
what they're saying is for a lot of these,
a lot of these people that
are there making these, uh,
these diets for these dogs,
there's like a big debate on whether
or not it's healthy for the dogs.
It's about the Vegas. He can
die. It's for, for dogs and cats,
whether or not it's a matter of,
uh,
the animal getting all the
proper nutrients or just
being able to stay alive.
So I don't really understand people's
relationships with dogs in that sense.
Like I get the whole, like
men having a dog, but people
get weird. So like we have,
we know a, um, a friend
of a friend who, um,
told us they have a patient
who's got munch houses, you
know, winch houses. Yeah.
Basically.
So they basically make up things so
that you can get their dog operated on.
Like it's just like as an them,
so that they have an excuse to get
an operation on the adult psych.
Like it's like that kid.
Oh.
Apparently what they're saying is that
dogs and cats have a much different
nutritional requirements than
human beings. And that the, uh,
they need much higher protein
intake than a human does.
So especially dogs can eat a bunch of
other shit like yams and potatoes and all
these different things and it's okay as
long as they get sufficient amount of
protein,
but it's almost impossible to get the
amount of protein that a dog needs with
just plants and cats. It's a
fucking joke. Cancer, you know,
here's what, you know, put,
put layouts and fucking meat
and lay out a bowl of beans.
See where fluffy goes. Fluffy.
No, you're not a murderer.
Fluffy dogs. Just choking down
these pieces of meat, you know,
have the yams
fluffy fucking ridiculous.
Here's the caps.
We would shut the fuck up.
That thing's a murderer, man.
You're going to keep it. Keep
it from being a murderer.
It's, it's nature. I mean,
you know, it's what it does. That's
what a cat does. It's kind of comedy,
like everybody who's been pushing all the,
like the Tofu and all the soy stuff
over the last couple of years,
it's starting to get breast cancer in men.
It's just,
you're discovering it's bad for you.
I say that stuff instead of milk and
I'd always feel sick, but I was like,
it's gotta be healthy for you.
Everyone keeps telling me that.
[inaudible] Bibbs that's why I have boobs.
Yeah.
Even vegan cats.com is telling
people to feed their cats meet.
That's when shit gets real.
When Vegan cats.com tells
people to feed their cats,
meet after much soul searching.
We've decided that we need
to keep our cats alone.
We only feed them asshole cows.
Cows,
it stomp on rats or something.
She walks into a room.
I'm gone.
Cat White cat
cats and hookers. Hookers.
You hate strippers,
man in Thailand. He just said one
touches him. He just freaks out.
Is that because of your experiences
in in Thailand or is it just like a,
it's like a thing in your DNA
perhaps from past lives maybe.
Will you ever stop to death by a
hooker or a stripper dude back.
She's talking about that you
haven't gone to Thailand.
I don't know if you ever go to Thailand,
man. The most vicious things you've seen.
You sit in the hospitals,
the chicks with the guys they bottle.
Like if you're going to fall with a guy
that chicks the hook chicks all Yay,
smash a bottle. Like they're like known
for it. And especially like Petaja. Yeah,
like that area.
The chicks,
the first thing of a guy gets
an arguing with another guy,
they'll stand up for them and bottle
the dude over her shoulder bottling.
I don't know what it is so effective.
Especially if you're a woman,
you don't have a lot of physical strength.
You hit a guy with a bottle and open
them up like a fucking tomato. Yeah.
Bottles are scary. Shit. When I lived
in Boston, I saw an argument over,
I don't know what the argument was
because I was a fair bit of way.
Like you know,
several others by these guys were arguing
and the guy's first move was to hit
this guy in the face with a
Heineken bottle. It was horrible.
It just caught him wide open.
He's bleeding all over the place and
they tackled the guy who did it and the
bouncers beat the shit out of him.
But I remember thinking like, man,
you gotta be real fucking
careful who you're fighting with,
who you're arguing with.
Addison it,
this guy just smashed this guy
and it just caught them open.
It's bleeding everywhere,
Matt. Good. Yeah,
but you know what the thing I was going
to say is I'd always shocks me when you
see dudes in another country
like Vietnam, Thailand, Brazil,
starting fights with the locals.
Don't fucking thinking people
were stupid as fuck man.
I think it's probably just DNA,
like wanting to get eradicated.
Like you have some shitty jeans and your
Eugene's want you just to
be taken out of the mix.
You know it's like a suicide
pill. Fuck Thailand. They're like,
Oh really? Okay. You have no idea
and you're drunk every night.
So I'm sure they start a fight with a
taxi driver and the whole of Thailand
jumps in. Do you live in Thailand now or
do you go back and forth? Back and forth?
Since I was 18 I'm 31 so wow. Long
time. And you tried to live there?
I tried to live there, but you know, it's
actually, I mean like I love Thai people.
I love the country. I love everything
about it. It's very ancient.
It's free, there's no rush. It's
beautiful. The Thai people are amazing.
Most of my friends there are tight.
But um, you know, after awhile
you just get,
I'll just go a little bit bored.
I had my brother back in Sydney as well.
He was running the gym. Um, you know,
he got up,
he got to stage where he was doing the
rescue and I think he got really attached
to not just, and that meant, you
know, the thing of saying like,
we were talking about this
before me and him like, you know,
like when you finished
profile and what do you do?
And I think like it was kind
of like, you're not, you know,
you're doing all this fighting and
you being admired and your brain and
everybody's doin and afterwards you
stop and you're just like, well now,
so he's going over to
Thailand and you know,
he's rescuing people and it's suddenly
a feeling important again. Right.
But he got really attached and I'm
actually at one stage I wanted to go live
there and um,
we had a,
we had a few arguments about
it and eventually I just said,
I think you should go because I didn't
want it that Jim had made a be holding
him back and he went there and
two months later he's like,
I'm ready to come home.
Did you ever think about competing in
Jujitsu to maybe just explain spark your
competitive desires and
avoid like head trauma?
I competed it a fair bit in Jujitsu
and I loved it, you know? Um,
but you know, I dunno like when I
hit, when I was there for those two,
three months last year, luckily I'm set.
I got really addicted to the abbots.
It was an adrenaline rush. Like
why cops say that? Well, you know,
you hear the radio go off. I listened
to the coat. I'm thinking, okay,
it's a car accident. There could be,
we could be cutting people out of cars.
We could be saving people, you know,
one accident I'll wait to like,
I was trying to actually put back
three bodies back together over like,
I don't know, quarter mile and a hundred
meters. It's less than a quarter mile.
How'd you meet her?
Is trying to put everyone back together
and it was a crazy adrenaline rush.
Put them back together,
meaning saved a lot of figure out
whose arm and leg was who's, oh Geez.
Two blacks collided dead people.
Lots and lots of bodies.
There's an adrenaline rush and
trying to figure out dope puzzles.
They're dretler rush.
Wasn't that,
I think I became like a little
bit desensitized to everything.
Like nothing bothered me.
I've seen everything,
but it was more when the alarm went off
in my little rescue about to set us a
room half this size of this and you
hear the code and all you hear is it's a
car. There's an accident, but
you don't know how many people,
you don't know anything. So you get
there and it could be like five cars.
One time we got there,
I was driving and they hated me driving.
Like I was telling my brother in the car,
why is it was like a v eight turbocharged
ambulances thing and they said I'm a
bad driver. I drove a Lamborghini
yesterday up at Vegas that was sick.
Or you went to one of those
places where you go, Oh yeah man,
I trust me by seeing I'd be driving.
And then after awhile they
started racing me to the,
to the driver's seat cause I just laid
next to the ambulance and he used to race
me there and I was like, man,
why did they, you know, I said,
why do you guys like me driving into more?
Said Dylan when you drive man,
where every religion and it sat with me
and I'm thinking what the hell are they
talking about? And they go, man,
we're Christian. We prayed to Allah,
we pray to Jesus Jewish goodnight.
You are such a mat.
You such a crazy driver that pretty
much pretty every God just in case
the fuck you did. You went from
motorcycle racing. Too many concussions.
I'll try kickboxing.
You go to fucking Thai boxing,
you become a world champion in Thai
boxing. Hmm. Not Enough Thrill.
I need a ride fucking bowls. Oh it
along the line. I can go rescue people.
Let's do it. Hey, what an adrenaline rush
I putting together bodies. Absolutely.
Yeah.
One thing I thought was interesting about
it though is you know he became quite
detached for a while eating candy
the whole time you hear it too.
What are you doing? You've
got a candy thing? Nah, just
sees it soothing my throat.
Your throat. Okay. Yeah. Both
of us got plenty of Vegas.
He kind of escaped the smoke.
That strategy cuts smoke indoors most
of the time you can't smoke indoors in
America. Most places Texas a few places
I think in Texas allow it, but it,
Vegas is one of the few places
left where you can smoke indoors,
but they have so many,
I don't usually have a problem with it
because they have so many like filters
and man, we got air cleaning
systems. Where'd you guys go? Uh,
you know Joe in Australia now. I think
you better look it up, but just in case.
Yeah, this is bro. Knowledge is
knowledge goes deep on this show.
We've been promoting bro
Science for four years,
but I'm pretty sure that they all that
passed in the law that anyone born after
the year 2000 can never buy cigarettes.
It's illegal.
So it's out first
generation of non smokers.
I, I liked that and I don't like that at
the same time cause I don't like anybody
telling me what I can again of course.
But I like it because kids are so god
damn easily tricked or we sparked by and
those chemicals that they put in
cigarettes that make them more addictive.
Did you ever see that movie inside job?
Russell Crowe. He's your boy, right?
Russell Crowe has from the air is,
um, it's a great fucking movie man.
And it d it's a, it's a true story based
on a real chemist who the whistleblower,
right? Developing. Yeah.
Specific compounds designed to keep
people addicted and he details, uh,
the, the mechanism involved in these, uh,
addiction processes. And it's like, wow,
how the fuck did the government
let this shit get in there?
I have a lot of trouble quitting smoking.
I was smoking while I was fighting and
I got to the point where I was like,
I get sick a lot because you're
smoking and fighting. I was only 20.
You were smoking and finding say well that
isn't sacral Raba famous for that. Um,
yeah. I mean the thing about smoking
it, man, I wish I never started,
but I started when I was about 13 and I
thought it was cool. It was an idiot. And,
but, but tell him was 21. It
was still smoking. I couldn't
quit. I'm not dipping. Um,
or you got damp know he knows I
hate it meant I couldn't quit it.
And you know,
I got to the stage where I was like,
after either quit martial arts to quit
smoking and I couldn't quit smoking
because I was getting sick a lot
from my lungs and my sinuses.
So I'd go train and then
don't have a cigarette. Wow.
And it was so addictive and it was really
a scary thing. That's crazy. What time,
what kind did you smoke?
Normal cigarettes, you know,
I've never tried those American spirits.
They have a cigarettes that are all
natural. They don't have any additives.
We smoke. Look at me, we started as
teenagers, as stupid idiots and you know,
everyone just, that's what you did
socially when you'd meet up in smoke.
But I was actually one of the last ones
smoking and I felt really down on myself
really like week about
the fact I couldn't quit.
I quit when I was 22 which was like 11
years ago. But I haven't. But you know,
like I actually got to a stage where I
was that addicted to it that I couldn't,
I almost quit like
training cause I couldn't,
my health couldn't put up with physical
exercise and I'm not surprised, man.
That's tough. Will fuck you up. I
absolutely agree. It's a massive prize.
I everyone that I know that they'd had a
cigarette addiction and then quit still
longs for those. God Damn, I don't,
once I quit I quit. You know? Yeah.
My friend Jeff. So this day he means he's
quit for more than a decade. He's like,
to this day, every now and then I'll see
someone smoking and just look so good.
I just want one punch them in the face.
When I was in the casino and there's guys,
there's kids right next to a guy blowing
smoke and I mean I'm thinking like,
okay, well you just hit him with a
car, you know, like yeah, I, you know,
I have a real problem with that.
People just don't give a fuck about that.
That's a weird thing
about the cigarettes too,
is that it affects the people around
you and they don't give us farther.
Absolutely. It's also the thing that
they throw them on the ground. Yeah.
Cigarette people are so likely to litter.
It's the weirdest thing.
Like they don't have any problem with it.
It's like almost on,
on average more people that
smoked cigarettes litter
with those cigarettes and
anything.
I had a guy over my fucking house that
was working on my house and he's sitting
out in my backyard and he smokes and then
he throws a cigarette on the gun and I
go,
what the fuck are you doing?
I mean you really littering in my fucking
backyard while you work. Dickhead.
Tradies just a Douche bag man suggest,
but I couldn't believe it. He did
it right in front of me. I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing man?
I live here.
You're just going to throw shit on the
ground. Step on it. Oh, you stepped on it.
It's good. Now. It has gone. Someone tried
to tell me, oh, they're biodegradable.
Yeah. In a fucking hundred
years. In a hundred years,
it'll go back into the earth.
You fucking nitwit or the daughters
at the beach. She's like, Hey Daddy,
look at this. Look what I found is either
a condom or a cigarette or degradable.
You fucking
Dildo just ruins a good base.
Biodegradable. What does it mean?
What are you talking about?
It's a foam fucking plastic filter at
the end of a shitty piece of paper.
Yeah.
Eventually the earth will absorb it so
you know what else is biodegradable your
fucking car. Leave your car for
a thousand years and won't exist.
Did you ever,
have you ever picked up?
I hate when people put them in
bottles and picked up a big,
all your thought was yours
and you're just like, oh,
that's the nastiest shit of all
fear.
It's cigarette ashes.
How about they throw
them out the window too?
That's a half the fires in California
from shitheads trailers throwing fucking
cigarettes out there and he'd do it
all the time. Driving on the highway.
Every day you will see some shit
head throw cigarette out the window.
They're not flicking it at you. They
don't think they're doing anything wrong.
I feel like it's,
they're doing something so bad to their
own body that they don't give a fuck.
They don't give a fuck about
poison their own bodies.
poisoning the earth itself.
The worst thing is seeing
the people smoking.
We're going to wrap this thing up anyway.
The attention span, it's not really,
it's where at six o'clock already.
It's been a lot of fun, dude.
Three hour podcasts.
[inaudible] you got to
sick. Reznikov is today, but
no worries. It was great. It was
fun. No, it was fun. It was really,
I'm glad we did this. Yeah. Cool.
So, uh, your gym give people the, uh,
the w how did they get ahold of you?
What's the website?
Yeah, it's okay. So a, Jim's a ww w. Dot.
Vitti www 2014.
True.
What about http?
I don't think you need in that anymore.
I always got the slashes backwards.
But um, what's name, okay, no word.
Vt One academy. [inaudible] DOT com.
That's [inaudible] dot com. There you go.
There's the website on the left.
Just one quick thing.
Do you know that a lot of French
girls in Canada called Lawrence?
That's really weird.
Last name or first,
cause I was on Tinder there that we found
their first name or the last name you
cycled back that big Chinese guy on
the left there. When I say Lawrence,
I think of a big giant ego with a
guillotine that kills you. Right Lawrence.
But on, on Tinder, all the girls were
Lawrence. That's so weird. Really Weird.
Tinder in the house and a random
note getting [inaudible] gone.
So that's us down there, come visit
us. We really friendly everything.
And the other side is peak peak-at-u.com.
Huh? Oh, other side is peak peak,
PW k Pwee k dash@eighty-u.com.
So why are you, what does that,
that's a, that's the project,
the growing down site
that we're working on.
We're going to put all like the stuff
at the talent stuff on and we've got the
psychologist, she's doing the podcast
on and stuff. So that's um, um,
that's sal kind of sat.
We're just going to host everything
cause that's our business side obviously.
Okay. So just means to
find out what is it again?
It's so it's pick p p
e k Dash Dash Dash um,
you at 80 dash.
Why are you.com?
That's um, that's uh, that's not up
there yet. I'm just pointing at Joe. I'm,
this
is awkward. Okay. Alright. There we go.
That's the going down site and
that's going to have all the toilets.
So let's just going to have a lot of
projects growing down, growing downs,
a project we launched
because we were sick of,
I'm basically throwing up sick or growing
up or being at the dinner table and
everyone comes up tutors. So, uh, what
you're doing with yourself lately,
are you working hard? That's our
South African accent, right know.
So my friends are psychologists and he
just started getting pissed off and so he
coined this whole growing down thing,
which is about stop listening to other
people and start fucking listen to
yourself basically. Yeah, that's
a great idea. Cause by the way,
not only what other people
give you shitty advice,
they will give you shitty advice because
they got shitty advice and they want
you to continue the
tradition of suffering.
People love watching people fail and
struggle because they've failed and
struggled. It's very rare that someone
would tell you, listen to me, I failed.
My life is a fucking disaster. Don't
do what I did. They don't do it.
Why don't you fucking grow up?
I've never heard anyone say that.
I've had many people tell me to grow up.
I've had many people that were fucking
miserable telling me that I needed to
grow up. I'm like, I don't get it. I'm
happy you're not and I need to grow up.
This is baffling.
Do you know you're gonna die?
I'm gonna die isn't the whole point.
Do enjoy this as much as possible.
I feel like I'm enjoying it
and I feel like you're not.
So I'm super confused as to why you're
giving me advice. One quick thing,
just before we wrap up,
I just wanted to share because I,
it just was something interesting that
came up were when we were backstage at
the UFC, right? And this is about
growing down and we're back there.
I'll fighters prepared pretty
well for the flight, right? Um,
and you go there and everybody's
telling you what to do. Don't eat bread,
don't eat this. Switch a potato or sweet
potato and everyone means well, right,
cut weight this way. Cut Weight
that way. Prepare this way.
Guys were holding pads hard as they
could the night before the fire.
Now we take it,
we taper a week before and we're there
and I'll fly to starts getting nervous.
You know when he starts copying a little
bit, because these are professionals,
right? Like we're professionals
too, but we study, you know,
we know what we're doing,
but he starts switching to sweet potato.
It cuts out bread.
He starts training a little bit
closer to the fight then he should be.
And the thing was was like everybody
was telling everybody what to do and he
ended up dropping five pounds by mistake
because he changed everything that week.
And I was like,
I was thinking about for comedy for
fighting and all that stuff is like,
it's really fucking hard
to just trust that look,
I've in potatoes and
red meat my whole life.
Let's just keep doing it until the fight,
you know?
And so that's what the
whole growing down it was.
It seems like if those guys are given
that advice and how to lose weight,
that seems like good advice.
Well he seems like the
[inaudible] wait till the last,
it's probably because he probably
should be lighter in the first place.
I looked at it as a healthier diet.
The advice is right,
but the timing is wrong.
Like you're about to go up on stage
and some guy comes up, he goes, man,
before I go on stage, I usually go do a
quick shot. I like to kill her up my nose.
That works for me.
And then you go and do what you got
to station everything sniffling,
you're bleeding. So it was just, you know,
for all the Aussies coming
up is just have a confidence
in what you're doing is good.
Write notes and do it after the fight.
And that was just something we
learned backstage. You know?
It's definitely good point
about tapering off, man.
That's one thing that people make a huge
mistake about [inaudible] they train
too hard. They think it's good to
train hard the day before the fight,
but training breaks the body down.
The whole purpose of training
is to break the body down.
If you don't understand that,
then you need to talk to someone who's
an exercise physiologist and understand
what is the purpose of working
out, working out taxes, the
body. So the body heals.
Healing is what makes you stronger.
The breaking down of the body forces your
body to react to the fact that you're
making it do all this work. So he
goes, okay, we're lifting weights.
Now we got to get stronger because this
mother fucker wants us carrying heavy
things all the time. Okay, this
guy wants us running up hills. Boy,
we better increase our vo two Max
because we want to stay alive.
Obviously the body has different
requirements now we need more oxygen.
But to break it down the week
of is really not beneficial.
You some guys do it though and they
get away with it. So I'll guide it,
looks at them and he goes, fuck this
is a pro. I better do it. It is. Well,
there's a lot of schools of thought.
I mean it's just like hard training.
You know,
there's a lot of schools of thought
when it comes to hard sparring and then
there's,
you know,
even pros like I was like Martin Kampmann
they say you should spar once a week
at most. Yeah, he's very good,
very smart and very technical but you
know a lot of guys didn't do it that way
and they have suffered because of it.
There's a lot of damage that
gets done that's unnecessary.
Whether it's in training, whether
it's a, you know, in preparation,
strength and conditioning, whatever it
is. There's a lot of unnecessary damage.
And what we were talking about
before about MMA training,
I think it's still in a learning period.
I think we still haven't got it down
the way. Like say football has it down,
they know exactly how to train to
develop like top flight football players,
basketball, same thing. You
go to a basketball camp,
you're dealing with top flight
strength and conditioning coach.
They really know how to deal with,
I mean you're dealing with multi,
multimillion dollar athletes and they
have that investment and they want to keep
it healthy and really no one should
apply that more than MMA fighters because
who the fuck gets hurt
more than MMA fighter
Whiteside? And Woodside probably is
the list taught sport in the world,
especially in Thailand because there is
no history of teaching. So it was like,
what is teaching fighters? They just
copied wise and loose pretty much.
So I was like, that's one of the most
backward sports in the world of them.
I never may. And there isn't a lot
of smoking and drinking as well.
I mean we had better now better.
They've gotten a lot of um,
you know, fight against alcohol, fight
against drugs. This is a lot of promotion.
Now you've got a lot of guys like yachts
and Clive Fairtex and mallow pedal.
He's actually American, um, you know,
and balk out. And these guys are heroes.
So for people there's a lot more
pushed towards the be healthy,
get fit. You can make good
money now you can go to Japan,
you can fight in a very car dude dives.
Yeah.
I have friends that that trained in font
and Thailand and they were telling me
about everybody's smoking cigarettes.
And I have my friend Chris started smoking
when he was in Thailand because he's
fighting, he's fighting in
Thailand. Everybody was training
and smoking and he started smoking too,
just like to be one of the gang.
Now he smoke cigarettes, you know,
share Champa cat, some grit, you know,
I've heard the name, he's the only like
Tom Post sort of base where we were.
Oh really? We broke a record. Rufus,
his leg. You've seen the fight,
I'm sure in other wineries. He puts
him and he breaks his leg the fall.
I didn't see that food drive. It's
on youtube. It's worth watching.
But we saw him and he's, I mean, he's a
legend for Andy Hug before all these guys.
Right. And we go to Thailand and Petaja
and he's just sitting there smoking.
So if I buy them a box of cigarettes,
he'll let me film him kicking the bag,
keeping a box of cigarettes, and he kicked
the bag for me. Show me the technique.
Like they're just smoking and alcohol
over there's adequate control. Wow.
Last question before we go. Um,
I'm a big fan of a, of kickboxing,
obviously kickboxing's starting to make
its way into the United States, uh,
in a big way with Gloria Loris then yes,
on spike.
My only problem with it is
I don't like tournaments.
I don't like the idea of making
someone fight twice in the night.
And I definitely don't like them doing
it with like high level kickboxing.
Like Nathan Corbett, um, fought,
uh, gold con sockets, right?
Go Con Saki knocked him
out in the first round.
Broke is a eardrum that stopped
the fight and then he had to,
he had to go into the final round.
Go on. Saki did against Tyrone Spong.
We're Tyrone Spong
fought three hard rounds,
this young Brazilian kid and then fought
in the round and brokers, it's anger.
I don't think this Shin break came
from the fact that he had a fight three
rounds and coke on how to fight one,
but the idea that one guy could fight
one round and then the other guy could go
three rounds to go to war and
then they meet in the finals.
I think that's fucking crazy and I think
in this day and age in 2014 with what
we know about concussed fighters,
exact head injuries and then taking a
break and cooling down in between that
fight in having an hour in between
the first fight in the second,
I think it's fucking crazy.
But also the removal of Klich makes
it fucking desk elbows, no elbows,
no clinch won that fight
I think with Elvis.
Well he's a real moitai specialist.
I mean he is an elbow guy and they
took away one of his best weapons.
That's really the clinch and the
elbows to two of his best weapon.
The thing about Gloria though
for us is that it's getting
a house on a big scale,
which is good. Like in that
way. It's good. I understand
the tournament, like your,
your perspective,
the tournament's kind of agreeing away,
but to get striking with
competing against the UFC so hard.
Yeah, it's hard. Well, I
think that first of all,
there aren't spike, which is a huge
company, isn't know spike is Viacom.
They're owned by huge, huge,
huge billion dollar, you know,
backing behind them.
There's a shit load of money in,
in involved in spike and Viacom.
But I think that the tournament format
is dangerous. Yeah, I really do.
I think it's antiquated.
It's dangerous. I loved it.
That's why it's amazing to watch pride.
But I,
for the athletes when you're dealing
with world class athletes like a Tyrone
Spong, Lego con Saki, I just think
it's unfair and I think it's fucking,
it's the wrong way.
I almost feel like it's disrespectful
to the sport itself and the fight is to
force worldclass fighters to fight
more than once in the night I think is
outrageous
because the thing that was going to
say just quickly about that is, um,
one of the biggest problems I think with
Gloria is it's also going to reduce the,
the um,
like might sign America is basically
kickboxing with knees and elbows, right?
The clinch in Thailand is like 30,
40% of Thai boxing,
not in America, not in Holland.
Right. So you're single,
these guys coming into MMA and not,
it is,
it can increase head damage
because there's no clinching,
but also the skillsets
that come from the clinch,
they don't exist in him and
a yeah. You know? Yeah. Like
we see it a little bit with Anderson
Silva. You see what a few more Thai guys,
they know how to clench.
And this sounds really stupid
cause you got a bad neck.
But I was saying like,
if you get to clinch with like a tired,
like I don't,
I'm trying to say it modestly, like
real clinch, like Thai clinch. It's,
it's almost like doing flowing Greco
body locks back. Takes snap
downs. What do you like lion fine.
Do you ever watch lion fight?
What's that line fighter?
An organization in Vegas and they're
putting it mal pet fights for them.
They have a lot of really
high level people that are
coming over from Europe and
fighting for them. They got really
good fights they're putting on right.
That was Cyborg Christina sidewalk.
She lost to this a girl from a hot on her,
she said to fucking Muay Thai fights.
They're,
they're hard on her because she took me
out hormones. That's the bottom line.
She's such a nice lady. The
reality, I'm sure she's a nice lady,
but the reality is she
took me out hormones.
But you're saying they include clinch
clinches and elbows. Great. Yeah,
I mean they have it. It's a Kevin Ross
fights through them. They have, yes.
And you know, elbows clinch,
everything take downs. They, they,
they trip each other. They drop
each other. Yes. It is beautiful.
And it's the comprehensive full style of
[inaudible] and it's safer. It's better.
And it's also more lethal.
It's more effective. Elbows,
kicks, knees, everything.
What's um,
what's,
what's the premium card without
guy who fought not to even look,
he's got a long way to go. He's only,
you know, his first fight, right?
But he used more time where tie in the
clinch and like people were saying what,
what did he do there? And I was like,
that's like first day stuff in Thailand.
So I think Americans are robbing
themselves a bit by doing glory,
Not Moy, Thai, Thai. You know what I mean?
I couldn't agree more.
And I think we're on the same page as
far as the respect for the athletes,
making them fight more than once a night
against worldclass guys on an uneven
playing field.
Like you could have fought,
like you could fight a worldclass guy
and get rocked a bunch of times in three
rounds and be really fucked up in that
dressing room when you're preparing for
the title and the other guy lands a
head kick 15 seconds into the fight and
you're both fighting in the finals
against each other. I think that's crazy.
I've absolutely and they're going to
have a big tournament in La and I'm going
to be there. We're going to watch it
every time. I watch it every time too.
I'm a big supporter of it. I just think
they should reconsider. I just think,
and I wish they would go moy Thai style,
just fucking bring in the elbows clench.
They'll watch some of those line fights.
They're doing it and it's very,
it's great. They have him on access
TV. Yeah. Right. Gentlemen, thank good.
A pleasure. A successful fun podcast.
Thank you very much. Alright,
follow them on Twitter.
It's Vt,
one underscore m m a underscore
Sydney and uh, the website.
One more time. Oh, Vtu one
mma.com. Dot. Au. Okay. Beautiful.
Thank you guys. Appreciate it.
Thanks also to our sponsors.
Thanks to naturebox. Enjoy some
delicious healthy, nutritious snacks.
naturebox.com/rogan that's
naturebox.com/rogan go there.
Use that and you will get 50% off of your
first box. Thanks. Also to honor God,
honor God,
God on it.com go to o,
n n I t use the code word Rogan and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
Thanks also to stamps.com. Go to
stamps.com. Use The code word J,
r e and save yourself some mice.
We will be back tomorrow with um,
uh,
and dre is Antonopoulos who will,
dropped some fucking mad
knowledge about bitcoin. Um,
both ace freely and David Tell,
had to reschedule.
So there will be no podcast on Wednesday.
David tell would be back
on Tuesday the 29th. Uh,
next Monday I have Steve Maxwell on
and then Thursday Greg Fitz Simmons.
And then next Friday I'll be at the
Lobero theater in Santa Barbara with Joey
Coco Diaz. Alright, we love you
guys and we'll see you tomorrow.
Much love big cast.
Okay.